bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour l'ouverture de la session
extraordinaire au Sénat une session qui
débute avec l'examen de la loi santé et
pour nous présenter ce texte j'accueille
la sénatrice Catherine de roche bonjour
bonjour vous êtes rapporteur du projet
de loi sur la modernisation du système
de santé on s'attend à un bras de fer
entre la majorité sénatoriale et le
gouvernement en juillet la commission
des affaires sociales avait déjà
supprimé une cinquantaine d'articles sur
les 200 que compte le texte qu'est-ce
que vous reprochez à cette réforme on
reproche à cette réforme plusieurs
plusieurs choses d'abord un problème de
de forme c'est une une réforme qui en
fait a été très peu concertée puisqu'il
a fallu l'examen en à l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture pour que
des concertation soit mise en place à la
demande du Président de la République du
Premier ministre donc un texte qui est
arrivé assez court à l'Assemblée
nationale avec une concertation qui
s'est fait lors de l'examen du texte et
avec en effet un texte plétoré que nous
ne souhaitons pas appeler projet de loi
de modernisation de la santé mais
simplement un projet de loi relatif à la
santé tant c'est un texte un peu
Fourtout et surtout qui témoigne d'une
impréparation et d'une d'un manque
flagrant de concertation avec les
professions médicales et paramédicales
les les médecins qui manifestent en ce
moment même devant le sénap parle de loi
inadapté au vrais problèmes comme la
baisse de la démocratie de la
démographie médicale oui c'est un un
c'est à la fois un texte qui qui pour
les professions médicales euh vise à une
forme d'étatisation de de la médecine et
ce c'est ce sur quoi nous avons beaucoup
travaillé pour en faire un texte qui
soit celui de l'organisation réelle des
soins sur le terrain mais avec comme
partenaire les professionnels de santé
et qui soi au cœur du dispositif il y
avait par exemple un oubli majeur qui
était celui de médecin spécialiste qui
n'était pas du tout pas du tout intégré
à la réforme et on sent bien que sur le
terrain les professionnels de santé
s'organisent pour faire le le travail
pour pour avec les services publicqu et
les services privés obtenir un un bon
accès des soins ou le meilleur accès des
soins poss possiblebles et là le texte
balaye cette coopération qui existe déjà
alors par ailleurs la droite compte
supprimer deux mesures phares du texte
qui sont la généralisation du tier
payant et la mise en place du paquet de
tabac neutre est-ce que ça va être le
cas est-ce que un compromis peut être
avec le gouvernement là-dessus alors sur
la généralisation du tir payant je ne
pense qu'il n'y aura pas de compromis
puisque la ministre souhaite le rétablir
c'est une mesure qui inquiète les
médecins à deux égards celui peut-être à
terme d'une main mise des mutuelles sur
sur l'exercice libéral mais surtout des
difficultés d'application du texte qui
ne sont pas résolus au jour
d'aujourd'hui le le deuxième point le
pquet neutre le Sénat pris une position
très claire c'est en matière de de norme
quelle qu'elle soit nous souhaitons
désormais nous contenter des directives
européennes et ne pas faire de
surtransposition comme ça a été le cas
dans beaucoup de domaines on peut penser
à l'agriculture on peut penser à
d'autres domaines celui de la santé et
dire il y a une directive européenne
pour l'instant aller sur ce message on
en reste à la directive européenne et
une autre mesure qui pose également
problème c'est la suppression du délai
de réflexion de 7 jours pour pour une
IVG est-ce que là aussi le Sénat va
prendre une position ferme oui le Sénat
une position assez ferme qui est de dire
sur des sujets comme l'IVG ou sur les
dons d'organes il y a une révision
prévue des lois de bioéthique et c'est
dans ce cadre- làà que nous que nous
examinerons ces ces deux sujets oui un
dernier mot je sais que vous êtes
beaucoup entretenu avec Marie soltouren
la ministre de la Santé est-ce que vous
pensez qu'elle est prête à certains
compromis je pense que non on verra
l'usage de la séance non je pense qu'on
est des positions qui parfois sont très
contraires euh et qui sont vraiment des
oppositions de fond elle a les siennes
nous avons les nôtres je pense assez peu
au compromis on va suivre tout ça en
séance Catherine Deroche merci
beaucoupci beaucoup et tout de suite
donc direction l'hémicycle pour écouter
la discussion générale l'ordre du jour
appelle maintenant la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée de modernisation de
notre système de santé et dans la
discussion générale la parole maintenant
à Madame Marie soltouren ministre des
Affaires sociales de la santé et des
droits des
femmes vous avez la parole madame la
ministre merci monsieur le Président et
vous me permettrez de vous saluer tout
particulièrement en cette journée du 14
septembre puisque je crois savoir que
c'est votre anniversaire bah oui
merci Madame la
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs le projet de loi qui nous
réunit à partir d'aujourd'hui est un
texte pour
l'égalité c'est un texte pour les
Français pour leur vie quotidienne et
pour l'avenir de le s enfants c'est un
texte contre le
fatalisme contre le déclinisme qui
voudrait que notre pays dans la
tourmente internationale face à la crise
économique serait devenu incapable
d'offrir à chacune et à chacun les mêmes
droits les mêmes chances sans tenir
compte des évolutions des besoins des
attentes et des contraintes en matière
de santé parler d'égalité a longtemps
sonné comme une évidence notre système a
été fondé sur les grandes valeurs de la
solidarité et de
l'universalité et pourtant des millions
de nos concitoyens sont confrontés à
l'érosion de cette promesse républicaine
parce qu'ils sont moins informés que les
autres sur la manière de préserver leur
santé parce qu'ils sont parfois
contraints de renoncer à se soigner pour
des raisons financières parce qu'ils ont
du mal à s'orienter à se défendre dans
un système devenu complexe je parle de
tous ces Français qui vivront moins
longtemps que les autres du fait de leur
situation sociale et oui mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs d'un bout à
l'autre de la ligne B du RER en région
parisienne en quelques dizaines de
minutes de trajet on perd 3 ans
d'espérance de vie un cadre vit en
moyenne 7 ans de plus qu'un ouvrier et
cette réalité là nous ne pouvons pas
l'occulter ces inégalités elles prennent
racine dès le plus jeune âge elles se
trans transmettent parfois de génération
en génération plus inquiétante encore
elles se sont aggravées dans les années
2000 parce que les maladies chroniques
ont explosé parce que la population
parce que notre environnement fait peser
de nouveaux risques sur notre santé il y
avait en 2002 dans les familles
ouvrières quatre fois plus d'enfants
obèses que dans les familles de cadres
aujourd'hui il y en a 10 fois plus
comment imaginer donc face à une telle
situation qu'il soit possible de rester
immobile ou qu'il suffisse d'approfondir
des politiques qui ont montré leur li
Lim l'ambition que je porte depuis 3 ans
est assumé innové
adapté moderniser partout où c'est
nécessaire pour réduire les inégalités
d'accès aux soins les inégalités dans
l'accès au droit au sein de nos
territoires d'abord c'est le sens du
pacte territoire santé qui va permettre
à notre pays de franchir cette année le
cap des 800 maisons de santé et des 400
médecins accompagné dans le cadre de
leur installation dans les zones
sous-dotées c'est en poursuivant ce même
objectif d'égalité territorial que j'ai
mis fin aux tout et deux
qui pénalisaient les hôpitaux locaux
désormais des financements spécifiques
leur sont
accordés inégalité d'accessibilité
financière au droits de chacun ensuite
encadrement des dépassements
d'honoraires coup d'arrêt aux mesures de
désengagement de l'Assurance Maladie
relèvement des plafonds de la CMUC et de
l'aide à la complémentaire santé demain
matin se tiendra la commission annuelle
des comptes de la santé qui le
confirmera à nouveau après plus de 10
années de hausse ce qui reste à la
charge des Français en matière de santé
diminue régulièrement depuis 2012 et
cette diminution une fois de plus a été
constatée l'année écoulée oui en un peu
plus de 3 ans à peine de premiers
résultats sont visibles mais cette
nouvelle donne ne peut pas être un
prétexte à l'immobilisme à l'inaction
elle nous invite au contraire à
maintenir le cap à poursuivre à
amplifier la modernisation de notre
système de santé parce que ce qui s'est
passé depuis 3 ans montre que l'action
produit des résultats et donc cela doit
nous amener avec volonté avec ténacité à
poursuivre à amplifier l'action pour que
de nouveaux résultats soient au
rendez-vous et l'enjeu qui est
aujourd'hui devant nous ce qui est au
cœur de ce projet de loi c'est donc de
continuer à innover innover dans
l'organisation des soins en passant d'un
système qui est aujourd'hui cloisonné
trop centré sur l'hôpital à une médecine
de parcours et de proximité structurée
autour our du médecin traitant et à
partir du médecin traitant à partir
également bien sûr des besoins du
patient innover en matière de prévention
en permettant à nos concitoyens de mieux
protéger leur santé innover en matière
de démocratie sanitaire pour permettre
aux Français de s'informer mieux de
décider et de se
défendre notre pays en matière de santé
et pas d'ailleurs seulement en matière
de santé a trop souffert de déclaration
de principe les défis qui sont devant
nous inviteent à l'action assurément
mais aussi et surtout à l'innovation à
l'inventivité et à l'audace l'audace
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est acceptter de faire bouger les
lignes c'est reconnaître que des mesures
fortes nouvelles parfois radicales sont
nécessaires c'est assumer la
confrontation
avec certains
conservatism avec certains immobilismes
avec certaines inquiétudes aussi et avec
des des acteurs qui instrumentalisent
trop facilement l'économie pour balayer
les enjeux de santé publique tout cela
c'est ce qui fonde le texte que je porte
au nom du gouvernement il poursuit trois
grands objectifs mieux prévenir mieux
soigner en proximité et mieux renforcer
les droits
la prévention d'abord doit devenir le
socle de notre système de santé c'est un
tournant majeur tout le monde parle de
prévention mais la prévention
aujourd'hui la vérité oblige à le dire
n'a pas la place qu'elle devrait avoir
dans notre système de santé nombre de
maladies pourrait être évité en aidant
nos concitoyens à mieux se protéger par
de meilleures habitudes de meilleurs
comportements il faut agir dès le plus
jeune âge parce par que c'est là que se
creusent les inégalités de santé
qu'elles s'installent puisqu'elles sont
directement liées aux inégalités social
parcours éducatif en santé depuis la
maternelle jusqu'au lycée paquet de
cigarettes neutres interdiction de fumer
en voiture en présence d'un mineur
création d'un délit d'incitation à la
consommation excessive d'alcool meilleur
dépistage des infections sexuellement
transmissibles mise en place d'un
étiquetage nutritionnel clair et lisible
des aliments ouverture de salalles
expérimentation de salles de
consommation à moindre risque pour
accompagner les toxicomanes les plus
marginalisés vers le sevrage protection
des riverins amélioration des dépistages
et renforcement de la prévention des
risques y compris en prison ce sont
toutes ces mesures qui viennent étayer
la mise en place d'une véritable
stratégie de prévention à partir de
cette loi prévention cohérente innovante
et efficace qui marque une étape
historique pour la santé des Français
deuxème volet du projet de loi le
développement d'une médecine de
proximité articulé autour du médecin
traitant l'enjeu est ici de faire tomber
les barrières qui limitent l'accès au
soins que ces barrières soient
géographiques financière ou
administrative généralisation du tiers
payant mise en place d'une lettre de
liaison transmise par l'hôpital au
médecins traitant dont le patient sort
d'un établissement numéro d'appel
national unique pour joindre un médecin
de garde en dehors des heures
d'ouverture des cabinets médicaux
communauté territorial professionnel de
santé qui permettront de mettre en place
des parcours de soins coordonnés
rétablissement du service public
hospitaliers création des groupements
hospitaliers de territoire se sont
autant d'avancé résolu avec ce projet de
loi nous passons donc d'une d'une
organisation hospitalo centré à un
système qui fait du médecin généraliste
le centre de gravité de la prise en
charge du patient nous sommes mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs loin très
loin d'une supposée étatisation de la
médecine en France épouvantail brandi
depuis des mois à l'opposé même et de la
philosophie du texte et de de sa
rédaction et de sa lettre puisque vous
ne trouverez pas trace dans ce texte de
soumission de la médecine libérale à une
quelconque organisation étatique enfin
troisème volet de ce projet de loi le
renforcement des droits des patients et
le développement de la transparence nous
ouvrons ici une nouvelle étape en
reconnaissant aux patients de nouveaux
droits individuels et collectifs
renforcement du rôle des associations
d'usagers qui seront désormais présentes
dans toutes les agences sanitaires
nationales création de l'action de
groupe en santé et si l'on pense à
certains scandales récents on voit à
quel point cette mesure aurait permis
aux victimes de mieux se défendre droit
à l'oubli pour d'anciens malades du
cancer et à terme d'autres pathologies
mise à disposition des données
évidemment anonymisées de l'assurance
maladie au aux chercheurs aux start-up
et aux lanceurs d'alerte transparence
des relations entre les professionnels
de santé et les acteurs industriels
toutes les conventions d'expertise les
avantages en nature et leurs montants
seront rendu public chaque agent
sanitaire sera désormais doté d'un
déontologue dont le rapport public fera
état de l'ensemble des liens d'intérêt
c'est là une étape majeure parce que
cont à ce que certains imaginent l'état
du droit jusqu'à aujourd'hui ne le
permet pas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il n'a pas été possible de
prendre des dispositions jusqu'à
aujourd'hui qui inscrivent l'obligation
de déclarer les conventions d'expertise
qui peuvent unir des industriels avec
des professionnels de santé ce sera
possible désormais au terme de cette loi
ce projet de loi je l'ai construit je
l'ai élaboré dans l'échange et la
concertation
il a évolué au cours de cette
concertation et il continuera assurément
à évoluer c'est évidemment le sens du
travail parlementaire mais ses principes
sa cohérence ses mesures structurelles
et innovantes je les porterai jusqu'au
bout vous avez pour plusieurs d'entre
vous participé à l'un des 200 débats
régionaux qui se sont tenus sur le
territoire pour construire ce texte de
loi vous avez ainsi était partie
prenante de cette dynamique
participative la concertation le partage
la confrontation des points de vue j'ai
tenu à les poursuivre au Parlement à
l'Assemblée nationale l'examen du texte
en première lecture a permis d'avancer
dans deux
directions répondre d'abord aux
inquiétudes des médecins libéraux en
apportant des précisions et des
garanties nouvelles dans l'écriture même
du texte en particulier
sur l'organisation des parcours
structurés de façon explicite autour du
médecin généraliste et sur la
généralisation du tiers payant qui sera
mise en œuvre de manière simple c'est un
engagement
progressive d'ici 2017 avec une garantie
de rapidité de paiement inscrite dans la
loi et puis le travail avec les députés
a permis d'aller plus loin d'ouvrir des
champs nouveaux je pense à la santé
environnementale avec une plus grande
information au public en matière de
pollution de l'air l'introduction du
conceptte d'exposome et l'interdiction
du bisphénol A dans les jouets pour
enfants je pense aussi au droit des
femmes avec le renforcement de l'accès à
l'IVG au-delà de ce qui était prévu dans
le texte initial de loi et la
suppression du délai de
réflexion c'est avec cette même volonté
d'avancer et d'enrichir le texte que je
suis devant vous aujourd'hui dans un
contexte évidemment particulier votre
commission des affaires sociales a
supprimé ou significativement altéré
plusieurs mesures essentielles du texte
du Gouvernement généralisation du tiers
payant mise en place du paquet neutre
suppression du délai de réflexion pour
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
consentement présumé au don d'organes
qui existait pourtant déjà depuis la loi
kayav rétablissement du service public
hospitalier action en groupe action de
groupe pardon en santé ouverture de
l'accès aux données en santé la liste
n'est pas exhaustive mais elle est déjà
impressionnante au fond c'est la colonne
vertébrale même de la loi qui a été
supprimée et lorsqu'il n'y a plus de
corps de colonne vertébrale le corps en
général a du mal à se tenir le corps de
la loi cet amolie affessé et il n'a plus
que un lointain rapport avec
l'engagement du gouvernement en faveur
de la réduction des inégalités de la
proximité et des droits de nos
concitoyens parce que je crois
personnellement et au nom du
gouvernement profondément à la cohérence
de ce texte parce que j'ai à cœur de
répondre aux attentes de nos concitoyens
qui veulent que nous allions de l'avant
je vous proposerai des amendements
visant à réintroduire les mesures
structurelles du texte qui ont été
supprimé par la commission c'est
évidemment un enjeu démocratique que
devant vous y compris après le travail
en commission le gouvernement porte son
texte ses engagements devant les
Français et ses convictions c'est pour
le gouvernement pour moi un enjeu de
cohérence et de
crédibilité s'agissant des mesures
supprimées par votre majorité
sénatoriale en commission j'ai
conscience que la probabilité que ces
amendements soient
réadoptés
est comment dire relativement
faible mais pour autant j'ai fait le
choix de représenter ces textes ces
amendement parce que je suis attaché au
débat et parce que je respecte la place
du Sénat dans le travail parlementaire
et il me semble donc à la fois
respectueux et nécessaire que nous
puissions avoir devant les Français et
pas simplement en commission devant les
Français qui regardent nos débats les
discussions sur ces mesures
fondamentales je défendrai aussi ces
amendements avec la conviction que la
navette parlementaire permettra au
textees de regagner sa force et ses
ambitions d'origine mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
porter une loi c'est faire des choix
c'est défendre une vision de la société
ce projet de loi améliorera le quotidien
des Français il y aura un avant et un
après mieux protéger les Français faire
progresser notre système de santé pour
qu'il reste l'un des meilleurs au monde
alors même que les défis sont multiples
en un mot faire vivre notre république
sociale c'est l'engagement que j'ai pris
devant les Français vous pouvez compter
sur ma détermination pour le tenir et je
serai en tout cas très attentive à
l'écoute de toutes les suggestions que
faut que vous ferez pour que nous
puissions aller dans ce sens-là et
toujours améliorer la santé de nos
concitoyens je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est maintenant au président Alain
Milon corapporteur de la Commission
des affaires
sociales vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues annoncer de longues
dates ce projet Doig de santé arrive
devant le Sénat après une longue phase
de
préparation des modifications
substantielles apportées par le
gouvernement sur son propre texte et de
très nombreuses dispositions
supplémentairire plus de 150 articles
ajoutés lors du débat en Assemblée
nationale il jutapose des dispositions
d'importance extrêmement variable
portant sur un très grand nombre de
sujets de ce fait il se révèle difficile
à appréhender et et se prête mal aux
appréciations
globales si la commission des affaires
sociales a profondément modifier voire
supprimer beaucoup d'articles en raison
d'opposition de fond ou dans le souci de
résister à la tentation de l'inflation
législative
elle a également adopté sans
modification ou moyennant de simples
modifications rédactionnelles environ la
moitié des 200 ne9 articles du projet
transmis par l'Assemblée nationale ce
projet de loi constitue le premier grand
texte sur la santé depuis le vote de la
loi Hôpital Patient Santé et territoire
en
2009 la loi
HPST a fait profondément évoluer
l'organisation territoriale de notre
système de santé et plus personne ne
conteste aujourd'hui l'existence des
agences régionales de santé je note
d'ailleurs une tendance générale à leur
confier la recherche de solution à tous
les problème de soin peut-être
devrons-nous réfléchir une fois que les
ARS auront réussi à s'adapter à la
nouvelle organisation régionale à
recentrer leur responsabilités sur
quelques sujets
essentiels fondamentalement votre texte
madame la ministre ne remet pas en cause
la loi HPST même s' lui apporte des
modifications certaines d'entre elles
peuvent d'autant plus recueillir notre
accord que nous avions à l'époque au
Sénat soutenu des positions qui ne
s'étaient pas retrouvé dans le texte
final je pense notamment à la place des
médecins au sein de l'hôpital d'autres
aspects de votre texte en revanche ont
suscité de notre part de très sérieux
réserves voir une franche opposition
pour m'ent tenir aux dispositions
relatives à l'organisation des soins et
aux établissements de santé le texte
issu des discussions à l'Assemblée
nationale apporte certaines évolution
plutôt positive par rapport au projet
d'origine c'est cependant en réaction à
vos propositions initial à la suite de
négociations inextrémist et et alors
même que le texte allit être examiné par
l'Assemblée nationale en commission que
des orientations nouvelles ont été
adoptées vous nous avez indiqué madame
la ministre avoir mené de larges
concertations préalablement au dépôt du
texte mais pour qu'il y ait concertation
il ne suffit pas de réunir les acteurs
concernés encore faut-il entendre ce
qu'ils ont à dire les professionnels de
santé y ont tous insisté avec force ce
n'est qu'au dernier moment que que leur
avis a été partiellement pris en compte
en instituant à l'article 12 un service
territorial de santé au public le
stsp le projet de loi constituait un
texte d'hyper administration qui plçait
l'essentiel du pouvoir de décision entre
les mains des directeurs généraux des
agences régionales de santé et instaurer
une forme de planification ambulatoire
inacceptable pour les praticiens
libéraux l'Assemblée nationale a refondu
le texte en substituant au stsp une
autre formule la communauté
professionnelle de territoire de santé
le
CPTs la commission d'affaires social du
Sénat a toutefois jugé
indispensable de prendre davantage en
compte les initiatives des
professionnels de santé de terrain sans
lesquels rien ne peut se faire elle a
remplacé
les CPTs par les pôles de santé
renforcés il ne semble pas opportun en
effet de remettre en cause à chaque
nouvelle loi de santé des dispositifs
qui ont à peine eu le temps de se mettre
en place et qui puiser lorsqu'il
fonctionnent bien les groupements
hospitaliers de territoire les fameux
ght prévu par l'article 27 nous
paraissent susceptible d'offrir aux
hôpitaux publics
le moyen de s'adapter plus aisément aux
besoins des territoires et de permettre
à tous
d'accéder en toute sécurité à des soins
de qualité compte tenu des remontées du
terrain la commission a jugé nécessaire
de s'assurer que les ght soi portés par
les équipes soignantes et ne dépendent
pas d'une décision unilatérale des ARS
nous estimons également important que
les élus ne soient pas de simples
spectateurs du fonctionnement des ght
mais qu'ils puissent participer
activement à la définition de leur
stratégie d'autres modifications
importantes ont été introduites je pense
notamment au maintien des missions de
service public pour les établissements
de santé publique de santé privée à but
lucratif l'article 26 nous ne sommes pas
opposés au rétablissement d'une
étiquette service public attaché aux
établissements publics ou non lu
mais nous ne voyons aucune raison de
pénaliser les établissements privés qui
s'engagent à mener des missions de
service public à tarif opposable j'en
viens à un point qui pour nous n'a pas
sa place dans ce texte et qui
cristallise les oppositions et vous en
avez parlé madame la ministre il s'agit
de la mise en place du tiers payant
obligatoire et
généralisé la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat estime que cette
mesure à la mise en œuvre complexe
rompante avec les modalités exercice de
la médecine libérale n'a véritablement
n'est pas véritablement nécessaire dès
lors qu'elle s'applique déjà au publics
les plus fragiles et a été largement
adoptée par les médecins pour les
patients atteint d'inffection longue
durée je signale d'ailleurs à propos de
l'accès aux soins que la Commission des
Affaires social a adopté deux
amendements de MAM marchambo et Cohen
rendant automatique le renouvellement de
aide à la complémentaire santé pour les
béficiires de la de Laah et de la SPA
inutile pour l'accès aux soins des plus
démunis la génération du tiers payant
entraîne une crispation inutile obérant
tout progrès dans les discussions
conventionnelles sur des sujets
autrement plus urgents et importants
pour notre système de santé pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons et pour
d'autres que nous expliquerons dans le
cadre des votes des articles et des
amendements nous avons supprimé
l'article 18 du projet de loi plus
fondamentalement il m'a paraît qu'on ne
peut
aujourd'hui discuter d'une loi de santé
publique sans engager parallèlement une
réforme permettant de financer
durablement l'accès aux soins de tous la
réflexion ne devra pas porter uniquement
sur les sources du financement des
dépens sociale mais également sur
l'architecture même de la sécurité
sociale celle-ci doit être pilotée par
la seule autorité légitime pour définir
la politique de santé dans notre pays la
ou le ministre je suis également
convaincu à titre personnel qu'il est
possible de garantir la prise en charge
intégrale des dépenses de santé par
l'assurance maladie en procédant à une
simplification drastique des structures
de remboursement du fait qu'il n'aborde
pas la question du financement pérenne
des soins le projet de loit de
nécessairement incomplet bien
qu'incomplet à mes yeux le projet de
lois n'en demeure pas moins foisonnant
je n'ai en effet abordé que quelquesuns
des nombreux aspects mes collègues
corapporteurs Catherine de roche et
isisabe
douanau interviendront et évoqueront
successivement les autres chapitres
s'agissant en particulier de la
prévention ainsi que l'exposera madame
doano la composition la Commission des
affaires social appris le parti de ne
pas se payer de mots et de supprimer des
dispositions déclaratoires des
dispositions redondantes ou des
dispositions relevant notre texte c'est
cette même ligne c'est cette même ligne
que nous avons suivi dans les examens
des amendements soumis à notre assemblée
que nous avons commencé cet après-midi
durement je l'avoue je vous remercie
pour votre
écoute merci
monsieur le Président la parole est
maintenant à Madame Catherine de roche
coapporteur de la commission des
affaires
sociales vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues concernant la prévention
première partie du texte et vaste sujet
la commission des affaires sociales a
adopté nombre des dispositions issues du
texte de l'Assemblée nationale
l'assouplissement des conditions d'accès
à la contraception d'urgence des élèves
du second degré le renforcement de la
lutte contre la consommation excessive
d'alcool en particulier chez les plus
jeunes l'information des jeunes sur
l'examen de santé gratuit la
Signaléthique nutritionnelle facultatif
complémentaire sur les emballages
alimentaires ou encore l'encadrement de
l'usage des appareils de bronçage
artificiel sont autant de mesures qui
nous paraissent aller dans le bon sens
la Commission a souhaité préciser
l'article 55sb relatif à l'information
sur les photographies retouchées afin
d'en garantir la clarteté et la
constitutionnalité
elle en revanche supprimé la création
d'un délit pénal d'incitation à la
maigreur excessive ainsi que l'avait
montrer le rapport de Patricia chilinger
en 2008 notre collègue l'anoraxie est
une pathologie qui ne résulte pas d'une
simple incitation et cet article
aboutirait à pénaliser de manière
contre-productive un symptôme de la
maladie plusieurs autres dispositions de
ce chapitre ne nous paraissent pas
devoir être maintenues car le président
Milon l'a dit elle prétend faire évoluer
les pratiques de matière déclaratoire
sans prévoir de moyens correspondants ni
de réelle modification du droit en
vigueur dans un souci de bonne
législation la Commission a préféré les
supprimer même si les intentions étaient
loouables le projet de loi comporte 20
articles consacrés à la lutte contre le
tabagisme la commission des affaires
sociales en partage très clairement les
objectifs près de 40 ans après la loi
veille et la création des zones non
fumeures la lutte antitabac reste
d'actualité je ne reviens pas sur les
ravages sanitaires que vous connaissez
tous mais cette question de santé
publique tend à se doubler d'une
question sociale le tabagisme recule
chez les plus favorisés il est très
élevé chez les personnes à faible revenu
face à ce constat que faisons-nous il
est un levier dont nous connaissons
l'efficacité l'augmentation brutale de
la fiscalité donc des prix je rappelle
qu'en 2003 dans le cadre du premier plan
cancer une augmentation de 40 % des prix
du tabac a permis une chute de 32 % de
la consommation aucun ministre de la
Santé n'a depuis obtenu de pouvoir
répéter cette opération au 1er janvier
2015 rappelons-le aucune augmentation
n'est intervenue c'est pourquoi nous
soutenons la disposition adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale de cignature par
le ministre de la santé de
l'homologation des prix du tabac tout en
étant vigilant sur le marché parallèle
nous avons tous en tête ce chiffre
d'un/art des achats de tabac hors réseau
des buralistes d'après la dernière étude
réalisée pour le compte des industriels
l'administration des douanes confirme
cet ordre de grandeur tout en estimant à
20 % et non à 5 % la part des achats
transfrontaliers légaux cela change
assez fortement la donne sur les
priorités notre premier combat est
l'harmonisation fiscale au niveau
européen alors que nos voisins mènent
clairement une politique non coopérative
à propos des buralistes nous devons être
clair sur les principes nous ne pourrons
pas soutenir les buralistes en
difficulté en encourageant la
consommation du tabac mais nous devons
accompagner résolument l'évolution de
cette profession vers la
commercialisation d'autres biens et
services en repensant de façon
volontaristes leur place dans les
services publics en zones rurales où ils
souffrent particulièrement nous avons
ainsi aborder les articles tabac avec
détermination interdiction de la popul
la publicité résiduelle et du mescénna
des arômes des additif ventau mineur
réalisme sur les sanctions pénales la
taxation du chiffre d'affaires et
l'harmonisation européenne et
pragmatisme concernant la suppression
des vagons vapoteur ou la distance des
débits de tabac de même un très large
consensus établi au sein de notre
commission quant à la nécessité d'une
harmonisation européenne des avertiss
sanitaire présents sur les paquets de
cigarettes nous pensons qu'elle
constitue une étape importante alors que
certains de nos voisins n'imposent
encore aucun avertissement sanitaire
cette harmonisation n'exclut peut-être
pas que notre pays rallie un jour ses
partenaires à l'idée du paquet neutre
mais dans le cadre d'une révision de la
directive applicable à tous les
États-membres il nous a semblé qu'un
engagement isolé de la France en Europe
continentale sur ce point était
prématuré pour un bénéfice incertain et
de toute façon ilement quantifiable pour
cette seule mesure le texte comporte par
ailleurs d'importantes dispositions
relatives d'une part à l'action de
groupe en matière de santé et d'autre
part au régime de l'ouverture des
données de santé il nous a semblé que la
rédaction proposée était parvenue à un
équilibre satisfaisant permettant de
garantir un juste milieu entre
l'ouverture raisonnée des données de
santé qui est attendu depuis longtemps
et la protection des informations à
caractère personnel sur ces deux sujets
nous avons adopté plusieurs am d'ordre
principalement technique notamment à
l'initiative de notre collègue André
Richard rapporteur pour avis au nom de
la commission des lois permettant de
clarifier de préciser ou de renforcer
les garanties figurants dans le texte
par ailleurs les dispositions relative à
la démocratie sanitaire ont fait l'objet
d'un large accord en ce qui concerne le
droit à l'oubli le texte que nous allons
examiner impose aux associations de
malades aux représentants des assureurs
et au pouvoirs publics de s'entendre
pour permettre aux anciens malades du
cancer ou de certaines affections
chroniques d'accéder à une assurance
crédit dans les mêmes conditions que les
personnes n'ayant pas d'antécédents la
convention AAS a été ainsi modifiée il y
a quelques jours le 2 septembre afin de
mettre en œu ce dispositif en juillet la
Commission a choisi de s'entenir au
texte qui avait été proposé par le
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
privilégiant la démarche partenariale
mais on peut regretter que l'accord
trouvé n'aille pas assez loin et ceci
fera l'objet de débat en séance tels
sont monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues les
principales observations de la
commission des affaires sociales sur le
volet prévention de ce projet de loi je
vous remercie merci ma chère collèg la
parole est maintenant à Madame Élisabeth
douanau corapporteur de la commission
des affaires
sociales vous avez la parole madame le
rapporteur monsieur le Président Madame
Mame la ministre mes chers collègues
dans ce projet de loi il me revenait
plus particulièrement de suivre les
dispositions relative à la définition
générale de la politique de santé à la
santé environnementale à la santé au
travail à la formation des
professionnels de santé ainsi que les
mesures dites de simplification et
d'harmonisation qui sont regroupées au
sein du titre
5 la simplification est un est en effet
un objectif souvent affiché
mais malheureusement comme l'a déjà
souligné le président Alain Milon ce
projet de loi dans sa version issue de
l'Assemblée nationale se caractérisait
plutôt par un foisonnement de
disposition à caractère plus
déclaratif que normatif déjà satisfaite
par la législation actuelle ou entrant
dans un degré de détail relevant du
règlement ou de la
circulaire la commission des affaires
sociales s'est donc attachée à
distinguer les mesures ayant un un
impact réel sur notre système de santé
de celle dont la portée juridique ou
pratique n'est pas
avérée ce n'est pas le fond de ces
articles ou de ces amendements qui est
ici en question il ne s'agit pas de
contester l'intérêt de telle ou telle
action de santé publique le rôle de
telle ou telle profession de santé la
pertinence de telle ou telle pratique
professionnelle il s'agit simplement de
conserver à la loi
la fonction que lui assigne la
Constitution déterminer les principes
fondamentaux madame la ministre mes
chers collègues tous nous regrettons
l'inflation législative et les lois
bavardes le président de l'Assemblée
nationale lui-même s'en inquiétait avec
force à la fin du mois de juillet dans
la presse déplorant je cite des lois
trop volumineuses et la propension du
gouvernement à faire gonfler ses propres
textes au cours de la
procédure avec des mesures nouvelles
adoptées sans étude d'impact ni avis du
Conseil d'État autant de reproches qui
semblent pleinement s'appliquer au
présent projet de loi il convient donc
d'agir résolument pour mettre en accord
notre volonté et nos pratiques et
garantir ainsi la qualité de la
loi c'est pourquoi la commission des
affaires sociales a supprimé les
dispositions qui à ses yeux sont plutôt
d'ordre réglementaire les déclarations
d'objectifs dépourvu de porté normative
ou encore des demandes de rapport sur
des questions pouvant déjà trouver leurs
répones dans les publications
administratives ou scientifique
existante c'est dans cet esprit que nous
avons simplifié la rédaction de
l'article
1er qui définit les objectifs généraux
de la politique de santé et n'a pas
nécessairement à en énumérer tous les
aspects s'agissant des dispositions
relatives à la prévention le chapitre 4
du titre 1er traite des relations entre
la santé et l'environnement il s'agit là
d'un sujet majeur et dont l'importance
ne fera que croître à l'avenir je tiens
d'ailleurs à souligner ici que le Sénat
a joué depuis longtemps un rôle d'é
guuillon dans ce domaine alertant
régulièrement le gouvernement sur les
dangers que présentent pour la santé
humaine les atteintes portées à
l'environnement le texte du Gouvernement
ne comportait à l'origine que deux
articles consacrés à cette problématique
le premier un article sur la pollution
atmosphérique qui rejoint d'ailleurs les
préoccupations exprimées par la récente
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur le
coût économique et financier de la
pollution de l'air le deuxième
autorisant les préfets à prendre des des
mesures coercitives pour lutter contre
la présence d'amiante dans les immeubles
bâtis répondant là encore à des enjeux
soulevés de longuees dates par notre
assemblée je pense bien sûr ici au
rapport de la mission d'information de
2005 sur l'amiante puis au rapport de
suivi de cette mission d'information qui
a été rendue en 2014 par plusieurs de
nos
collègues lors de l'examen du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés ont
ont adopté de nombreux articles
additionnels dont plusieurs à
l'initiative du gouvernement ces
articles prévoi notamment de confier de
nouvelles missions à l'anèe de
réglementer l'usage des brumisateurs de
lutter contre les espèces nuisibles ou
bien encore de prévenir les risques liés
au bruit si ces mesures sont quelque peu
hétéroclites
elles vont dans le bon sens et la
commission leur a donc apporté son
soutien on peut en revanche regretter
que la santé au travail apparaisse comme
le parent pauvre de ce projet de loi
s'il offre une voie d'accès
supplémentaire à la spécialité de la
médecine du travail et constitue une
réponse à certaines aspirations de
reconversion ou de diversification des
parcours professionnels il est loin à
mon sens de contribuer à l'indispensable
renforcement de l'attractivité de cette
filière
médicale s'agissant de la formation des
professionnels de santé la Commission a
approuvé sans modification les articles
relatifs au développement professionnel
continu au stage des étudiants
paramédicaux au statut des assistants
dentaires et des assistants et des
étudiants sag-femme pardon enfin il faut
souligner que le projet de loi comprend
un nombre inhabituel d'habilitation du
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
10 article visant plus d'une centaine de
domaines plusieurs de ces sujets ne
présentent pas caractère purement
technique c'est pourquoi il nous a
semblé
indispensable que le Parlement puisse
les examiner dans le cadre normal de la
procédure
législative je pense en particulier aux
conditions de création de gestion
d'organisation et de fonctionnement des
centre de santé et des maisons de santé
à l'organisation de la transfusion
transfusion sanguine à l'accès aux soins
de premier recours aux règles relatives
aux ordres des professions de santé ou
encore au droits applicable aux
recherches
biomédicales mes chers collègues la
commission des affaires sociales a
souhaité élaborer un texte adapté aux
besoins de nos concitoyens
elle a également souhaité un texte plus
lisible recentré sur des dispositions
ayant un impact concret sur
l'organisation et le fonctionnement de
de notre système de santé elle vous
demande d'adopter ce projet de loi ainsi
modifié merci merci madame le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Jean-François longjau
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement
durable vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues sur les 209 articles du projet
de loi de
modernisation de notre système de santé
la Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
ne s'est saisi que de 17 articles qui
entrent directement dans le champ de sa
compétence 16 articles pour l'essentiel
ajouté lors du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale traitant des questions santé
et d'environnement et un article
malheureusement le seul relatif à la
lutte contre les déserts
médicaux en ce qui concerne les aspects
santé environnement la Commission
soutient la plupart des avancées du
projet de
loi la prise en compte de la notion
d'exposome le renforcement de la
surveillance des pollèes et moisissû de
l'air extérieur l'amélioration des
remontées d'information sur la miante et
le plomb la mise en place de de
référence pour l'exposition au
radon l'encadrement des brumisateurs
d'eau dans l'espace public ou encore
l'interdiction des jouets au biphénol
a je me félicite que ces dispositions
sont maintenu dans le texte élaboré par
la commission des affaires
sociales notre commission propose en
revanche d'aller plus loin en ce qui
concerne les appareils de bronzage à mon
initiative elle a adopté un amendement à
l'article 5 e à afin d'interdire
purement et simplement les cabines UV
d'un point de vue scientifique le doute
n'est plus permis on sait qu'une seule
exposition en cabine UV avant l'âge de
35 ans constitue un surrisque de
développer un cancer de la peau de 59 %.
on sait également que le nombre de
mélanomes a triplé entre 1980 et
2005 atteignant 9780 nouveaux cas et
1620 décès il est temp d' et notre
commission envoie un signal
fort cette interdiction est d'ailleurs
recommandée par l'Académie de médecine
depuis de nombreuses années est déjà
mise en œuvre au Brésil et en
Australie le débat en commission des
affaires sociales a fait ressortir la
nécessité de préciser les conditions
d'entrée en vigueur d'une telle
disposition j'ai donc rectifié notre
amendement de afin de bien renvoyer au
pouvoirs réglementaire le soin
d'édiicter ces mesures le le plus
important est que le principe de
l'interdiction des cabines UV soit
inscrit dans la loi en matière de lutte
contre les déserts médicaux les mesures
mises en œuvre par le gouvernement dans
le cadre du Pacte territoire santé ne
sont pas inutiles mais elles ne
permettront pas à ell seul de résoudre
l'inépineuse équation de la démographie
médicale à l'horizon
2020 il faut là aussi aller plus loin
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'avait recommandé
le président Moret dans son rapport de
2013 sur cette question je vous rappelle
que la France n'a jamais compté autant
de médecins
198365 en exercice régulier en 2015 dont
44,7 % de libéraux mais ils n'ont jamais
été aussi mal réparti sur le territoire
les écarts de densité varient de 1 à 4
entre les départements de l'UR qui
compte 167 médecins pour 100000
habitants et Paris qui en recens 678
pour toujours 100000
habitants globalement lesone médical du
centre de la France vers les régions
littorales et la façade est continue de
s'aggraver même la région Île-de-France
enregistre une diminution de 6 % de ces
médecins entre 2007 et 2015 je vous
rappelle enfin que si l'on observe la
situation encore plus finement au niveau
infra départemental on constate qu'il
existe des déserts médicaux dans tous
les départements y compris les
départements les mieux dotés par
ailleurs les écarts de dentité varient
également d'une spécialité à l'autre en
2014 ils sont de 1 à 2 pour les médecins
généralistes de 1 à 8 pour les médecins
spécialistes de 1 à 9 pour les
infirmiers libéraux de 1 à 4 pour les
masseurs
kinésithérapeutes de 1 à 5 pour les
sages-femmes et de 1 à 3 pour les
chirurgiens dentistes au final le
constat essé par Hervé Moré en 2013 ne
change pas 3 millions de Français vivent
dans un désert médical et même la
situation s'aggrave on est passé de
64778 médecins généralistes en 2007 à
58104 en 2015 soit une baisse de 10,3 %
et une diminution supplémentaire de 6,8
% est à prévoir d'ici
2020 quatre autres spécialités sont
également en souffrance la rhumatologie
- 10,3 % depuis
2009 la dermatologie - 7,7 % depuis 2009
la chirurgie générale - 4,7 % depuis
2009 et l'ORL - 7,8 % depuis
2009 quatre départements sont d'ors et
déjà dépourvus de certains
spécialistes certains spécialistes qui
SEM pourtant nécessaires contte tenu du
profil de leur population
la loser ne dispose ainsi d'aucun
neurologue ni rhumatologue tandis que la
Corse du Sud la Creuse et laameuse ne
compte aucun gériâtre dans l'ensemble
ces difficultés vont mécaniquement
continuer à s'accentuer si aucune
réponse forte n'est apportée le creux
démographique est attendu pour
2020 dans ce domaine les dispositifs mis
en place par presque tous les
gouvernements successifs depuis les
débuts des années 1990 à caractère
essentiellement incitatif n'ont pas eu
les effets escomptés par conséquent
notre commission a adapté à l'unanimité
deux amendements qui mettent en œuvre
concrètement les propositions du rapport
Moret de
2013 le premier consiste à avancer vers
la professionnalisation des études de
médecine au cours de mes auditions j'ai
appris et à ma grande surprise que
chaque année environ 25 % des médecins
diplômés d'une faculté française décide
finalement au terme d'un long cursus
d'étude de ne pas s'inscrire au tableau
de l'Ordre des médecins pour exercer une
autre profession autres professions dans
le journalisme ou l'administration par
exemple ce sont autant d'années d'études
de médecinees coûteuse qui sont financés
en pure perte par la société à cela
s'ajoute un problème plus spécifique de
la médecine générale qui ne séduit
toujours pas les futurs praticiens
seulement 46 % des places ouvertes en
médecine général sont occupés par des
internes pour éviter que les jeunes
diplômés n'abandonnent leur vocation au
bout de 11 ou 12 années d'études la
Commission souhaite leur permettre
d'appréhender le plus tôt possible les
contours de leur futur métier par le
biais d'une expérience de terrain en
amont deors cursus à l'heure actuelle la
France accuse un véritable retard en
matière de professionnalisation des
études de
médecine des pays comme le Canada ou
l'Estonie ont déjà complètement
réorienté leur mécanisme de formation
vers l'immersion
précoce notre commission souhaite par
conséquent ouvrir la brèche en prévoyant
que les études de médecine doivent
favoriser l'immersion précoce des
étudiants dans un environnement
professionnel
elle traduit cette volonté dans les
faits en rendant obligatoire un stage
d'initiation à la médecine générale dès
le 2e cycle des études de
médecine le PACT territoire Santé
prévoit un tel stage mais ne le rend pas
obligatoire l'arrêté du 8 avril 2013
prévoit quant à lui un stage ambulatoire
obligatoire mais il ne cible pas
spécifiquement la médecine générale nous
proposons simplement de fusionner les
deux afin d'obliger les universités à
promouvoir cette voie car empiriquement
on constate une chose plus les étudiants
pratiquent la mé générale plus il
l'aiment et plus ils la choisissent nous
devons donc surmonter l'obstruction de
certaines universités qui considèrent
que la médecine générale n'est pas une
spécialité et font F des stages
pratiques le second amendement vise à
mettre en place un dispositif de
régulation des installations des
médecins à l'instar de ce qui existe de
longue date chez les pharmaciens pour la
plupart des professionnels de santé
depuis 2008 infirmier sagefemme maeœur
kinésithérapeute
orthopomiste et chirurgien dentiste en
complément des aides à l'installation
dans les zones classées comme très
sousdoté ce dispose ce dispositif
propose une régulation des nouveaux
conventionnements dans les zones
surdotées fondées sur les règles sur la
règle une entrée pour un départ son
efficacité n'est plus à démontrer chez
chez les infirmiers par exemple il a
permis une progression des effectifs
dans les zones très sous-dotées de 33,5
% entre 2008 et 2011 ainsi qu'une
diminution des effectifs dans les zones
surdotées les autres exemples peuvent
être effectivement évoqués inversement
le conventionnement sélectif prend fin
lorsqu'il prend fin le sold de
desinstallations s'inverse à nouveau cet
effet a pu être observé chez les
masseurs kinésithérapeutes lorsque le
dispositif mis en place fin 2011 a été
annulé par le Conseil d'État le 17 avril
2014 pour défaut de base légale on a
observé une reprise presque immédiate
des installations en zone surdotée à
partir du de l'arrêt du
dispositif au final ce conventionnement
c'est ctif complète utilement les
mécanismes d'insitation en faveur des
zones sous-dotées ce sont les deux
piliers d'une même stratégie qui ne peut
fonctionner correctement si l'un vient à
manquer pour cette raison la Commission
estime qu'il est temps d'appliquer la
règle une entrée pour un départ au
médecins qui souhaitent s'installer dans
les zones surdotées la commission des
affaires sociales a effectué un pas en
cette direction en prévoyant une
obligation de négocier à partir de la
prochaine convention médicale avec
l'assurance maladie mais ce système que
nous avions également étudié pose deux
problèmes d'une part l'obligation concl
je conclus monsieur le Président
l'obligation de négocier n'offre pas de
garantie du
succès au final le nombre d'amendements
présentés par notre condition notre
commission est volontairement réduit
mais il s'agit de mesures courageus et
importantes pour la protection des
populations et des territoires le Sénat
en est le garant il nous appartient de
faire primer l'intérêt général je vous
merci monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant au
président pH en remplacement de notre
collègue André re rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des
lois
président madame la ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues
rapporteur mes chers collègues je me
dois tout d'abord d'excuser notre
rapporteur saisi pour avis andrch il est
retenu par un déplacement à l'étranger
qui s un peu prolongé il m'a chargé dans
la mesure de mes moyens de d'être son
porte-parole pour vous dire combien il a
été satisfait de la collaboration
excellente comme toujours que il a pu
avoir au nom de la commission des lois
avec votre commission des affaires
sociales voici un
texte qui comme trou souvent hélas est
un regroupement de dispos
sans grand lien entre
elles encore alourdi par de trop
nombreux amendements de l'Assemblée
nationale qui lui ont donné un volume
qui inspire l'impression que c'est un
texte obèse un de plus certains de ces
amendements piétinent d'ailleurs
largement le partage constitutionnel
entre la loi et le décret le président
de notre commission des affaires
sociales il a été d'ailleurs extrêmement
vigilant et je l' remercie nagerre on
appelé ce genre de loi
Fourtout servant de voiture balai
législative aux différentes dispositions
préparées par les bureaux du ministère
des affaires sociales un projet de loi
portant diverses dispositions d'ordre
social on affiche aujourd'hui des
ambitions plus élevées puisqu'on parle
de modernisation mais la réalité n'a
malheureusement pas changé il ne
m'appartient pas de m'étendre sur des
disosition comme celle relative au tiers
payant la commission des affaires
sociales a fait son travail en montrant
que cette proposition de réforme
comportait plus d'inconvénients que
d'avantage et je dois dire que je
partage entièrement son point de vue
mais la commission des lois s'est plus
particulièrement prononcé sur des
disposition qui comme souvent d'ailleurs
en matière de santé soulève des
questions très importante relative au
droits des personnes car dans le domaine
de la santé on n'est jamais loin de
question tout à fait fondamentale nous
l'avons vu encore il y a quelques mois
lorsque nous avons discuté ensemble de
la fin de vie la première de ces
questions c'est la question du nom
d'organe et je crois que il y avait lieu
ici de rechercher le bon équilibre entre
la garantie du respect de la volonté de
l'individu et le devoir de solidarité
envers les malades deux exigences l'une
et l'autre tout à fait fondamentales il
me semble que le compromis auquel nous
sommes parvenus avec la commission des
affaires sociales est un bon compromis
il faut être attentif dans les
dispositions légales que nous appliquons
à ne pas scandaliser les familles et les
proches alors que le deuil est déjà pour
eux si difficile à faire surtout tout
que l'origine du décès est généralement
accidentelle quand se pose la question
du prélèvement et le travail de deuil se
fait de manière accélérée quand surgit
aussi la question du prélèvement
d'organes alors même que les proches la
famille constatent que le malade placé
sous assistance respiratoire pour
préserver les organes continue à
respirer malgré son état de mort
clinique et le travail qui est fait dans
les services hospitaliers depuis un
certain nombre d'années notamment les
services de réanimation par les
infirmiers référents est un travail de
très grande qualité qu'il faut se garder
de perturber car ils accompagnent les
proches ils accompagnent les familles
pour leur permettre d'exprimer ce que
ses proches ses familles peuvent
connaître de la volonté du défunt on ne
peut pas se dispenser de ce travail
jamais un service hospitalier n'exercera
par un
prélèvement une forme de violence sur la
famille sans qu'il il cet accompagnement
et donc je me réjouis du travail qui a
été fait et qui permettra au Sénat une
fois de plus de montrer son souci d'un
bon équilibre respectueux des droits des
personnes
et reflétant une connaissance précise de
ce qui se passe réellement dans ces
moments souvent tragiques qu' quand il
s'agit de faire un prélèvement d'organe
il y a ensuite l'action de groupe en
matière de santé évidemment n'a rien à
voir avec le sujet précédent mais
pourtant il s'agit là aussi de déroger
un principe fondamental du droit selon
lequel nude ne plaide par procureur on
ne peut pas créer des dispositions qui
par leur généralité en viendrai alors
qu'en matière de santé la prise en
compte de la situation particulière de
chaque individu victime d'un éventuel
aléa thérapeutique ou d'une erreur ou
même d'une fraude dans dans
l'élaboration de d'un protocole médical
ou dans la mise au point ou
l'utilisation d'un
médicament peuvent avoir eu des effets
très différents pour les uns et pour les
autres vous avez bien pris en compte à
la commission des affaires sociales
notre préoccupation je vous en remercie
je crois que nous sommes arrivés
là-dessus à un compromis tout à fait
intéressant l'ouverture des données de
santé quel dommage de ne pas pouvoir
utiliser davantage pour élaborer nos
politiques de santé publique les données
si nombreuses et si précises qui sont
réunies par nos caisse d'assurance
maladie est centralisé à la Caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie je
comprends la motivation du projet de loi
qui consiste à dire qu'il faut que ces
données ne restent pas au fond de nos
ordinateurs et en même temps il y a le
respect du secret de la vie privée et
les exigences de la santé publique ne
peuvent porter d'atteintte excessive
à cette exigence du respect du secret de
la vie privée les informations médicales
étant évidemment des informations qui
touchent de très près à la vie privée de
chacune de chacun d'entre nous c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons là aussi
essayé de trouver un encadrement
suffisamment strict de l'exploitation de
ces données qui ne préjudicient pas au
respect de ces principes fondament
tout en permettant d'aller bien auelà de
l'exploitation qui existe actuellement
nous avons enfin des dispositions
relatives à l'hospitalisation sous
contrainte et là bien sûr la liberté
individuelle d'où découle le principe du
consentement libre et éclairé aux
soins trouve ses limites par la
nécessité de protéger l'individu atteint
de troubles psychiques aigu contre
lui-même et de protéger son entourage
voir la société
en tout cas les tiers face au risque
d'agression le meilleur encadrement des
mesures de contention prévu à l'article
13 quat qui résulte de la rédaction à
laquelle nous sommes parvenus ensemble
me paraît comme il paraît à André
Rechard tout à fait pertinent il y a une
autre question plus administrative
peut-être mais hautement symbolique
c'est le statut de l'infirmerie
psychiatrique de la ville de Paris qui
dépend de la préfect de police le
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté avait dénoncé cet
état de fait le projet de loi est
l'occasion
de tirer les conséquences de sa
recommandation c'est une question de
principe ça ne met pas en cause les
équipes gérant cette structure leur
professionnalisme et la grande qualité
de leur travail sont au contraire
parfaitement reconnu cette structure se
se révèle toujours aussi
utile il ne faut pas la supprimer mais
il est important que les mesures de
contrôle appliquées aux établissements
psychiatriques soit aussi impliqué à
cette infirmerie c'est ce que comporte
le texte qui est mis en discussion
aujourd'hui et ça permettra de faire
revenir cette structure sans équivalent
dans le droit commun de la santé
publique ce qui est une bonne chose la
commission des Lois vous propose donc
adoptter les articles dont elle s'est
saisie tels qu'ils ont été modifiés à
son initiative par la Commission des
Affaires social je vous remercie
merci monsieur le
Président Madame Françoise labor cor
rapporteur de la délégation au droits
des femmes et à l'égalité des chances
entre les hommes et les femmes pour 5
minutes avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues Annique
Billon et Mo même allons vous présenter
à de voix le rapport que nous avons eu
l'honneur de proposer à la délégation au
droits des femmes sur le projet de loi
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui nous n'avons
évidemment pas abordé tous les aspects
de la santé des femmes tant ce sujet est
vaste mais nous avons essayé d'élargir
l'information de la délégation à
certains thèmes assez représentatifs de
cette question je veux parler
principalement de contraception
d'urgence et des compétences des
sages-femmes en matière VG
médicamenteuse de vaccination et de
prescription de substitut nicotiniques
aux femmes enceintes et à leur
entourage ce rapport et les 28
recommandations dont il est assorti a
été adopté le 2 juillet à la quasi
unanimité de la délégation il s'appuie
sur deux constats la nécessité de
privilégier une approche de la santé qui
prenne mieux en compte les enjeux
spécifiques aux femmes c'est l'axe que
je vous présenterai dans un instant la
consolidation des acquis en matière de
santé sexuelle et reproductive c'est ma
collègue Annique billon qui interviendra
sur ce point je vais donc pour ma part
évoquer certaines des conclusions de la
délégation visant une meilleure prise en
compte des fragilités spécifiques aux
femmes parmi ces fragilités celles qui
relèvent des maladies cardio-vasculaires
ont plus particulièrement attiré notre
attention selon la Fédération Française
de Cardiologie la prise en charge d'un
infarctus pour les femmes est trop
souvent plus tardive que pour les hommes
les femmes semblent moins nombreuses à
recevoir un diagnostic exact le
dépistage est insuffisant pour les
femmes et leur rétablissement serait
plus aléatoire que celui des hommes les
risques liés aux maladies
cardiovasculaaires pour les femmes sont
donc insuffisamment connu alors qu'elles
sont la première cause de mortalité pour
les femmes ettu h fois plus que le
cancer du sein le constat de cette
fragilité m connu des femmes aux
maladies cardioas vculaire a conduit la
délégation à formuler une recommandation
pour améliorer la sensibilisation des
professionnels de santé sur ce point et
à mieux informer les femmes et leur
entourage à ce danger une association
américaine goide for women a pris
l'initiative depuis avril dernier d'en
informer le public français sur
certaines chaînes de télévision et avec
le partenariat de quelques marques de
luxe à quant une véritable campagne
nationale destinée au grand public dans
le domaine du cancer les informations
que nous avons recueillies soulignent
que des progrès peuvent encore être
accomplis en matière de prévention du
cancer du du cancer du col de l'utérus
l'une de nos recommandations en tire les
conséquences pour le dépistage autre
risque majeur l'augmentation du
tabagisme féminin directement
responsable de l'augmentation sensible
de la mortalité des femmes par cancer du
poumon alors que cette cause de
mortalité a diminué pour les hommes
une prévention précoce préconisée par
une autre de nos recommandations est
d'autant plus indispensable que selon un
rapport officiel une femme sur 6 fumait
encore quotidiennement en 2010 au cours
du 3e trimestre de sa
grossesse c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposerons de rétablir par amendement
le suivi expérimental des femmes
enceintes consommant régulièrement des
produits du tabac prévus à l'article 33
bis et supprimé par la commission des
affaires sociales
en ce qui concerne les violences et plus
particulièrement les violences sexuelles
dont les conséquences sur la santé sont
évidemment considérable il semble que le
repérage des victimes par les
professionnels de santé puisse encore
être amélioré notamment par une
meilleure sensibilisation aux aspects
juridiques de leur
intervention une autre recommandation
concerne le soutien des associations qui
permettent le suivi médical des femmes
en situation de précarité
victime en quelque sorte d'une double
peine nous comptons sur vous madame la
ministre pour que les restrictions
budgétaires ne se traduisent pas par une
baisse des financements versé à ces
organismes qui font sur le terrain un
travail absolument
remarquable en ce qui concerne les
risques environnementaux on sait que
l'exposition à des substances nocives au
cours des périodes prénatal et périnatal
et pendant l'adolescence a des
conséquences tout au long de la vie il
nous a donc semblé souhaitable de
préconiser le renforcement de
l'information des femmes enceintes des
parents et de tous les professionnels en
contact avec de jeunes enfants à la
toxicité de certains produits autre
point soulevé la maigreur excessive nous
soutenons le dispositif adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale ce sera l'un des
l'objet d'un des amendements que nous
vous proposerons enfin des chercheurs
ont attiré notre attention sur le fait
que les recherches
biomédicale et l'exercice de la médecine
ne sont pas exemp de stéréotypes
masculins et féminins ce qui peut être
lié d'après certaines sources à une
insuffisante représentation des femmes
dans des essais thérapeutiques aux
États-Unis les autorités ont pris la
mesure des conséquences de ce
déséquilibre depuis
1993 nous proposons qu'en France nous
prenions aussi ce genre de mesure enfin
et je pense qu'un certain nombre seront
d'accord avec nous à l'article 1er nous
vous proposerons un amendement qui vise
précisément à réintégrer dans la santé
dans le code de la santé publique
l'objectif d'égalité entre femmes et
hommes et en décliner les conséquences
jusque dans les essais clinique et
thérapeutique après cette liste à la
préverre je pense que je vais être
obligé de conclure et que je reviendrai
dans le cadre de la discussion je vais
juste dire l'égalité entre hommes et
femmes passe aussi par la santé
je vousci merci
maè la parole est maintenant notre
collègue an
guonpporte la délégation droit des
femmes à l'égalité des chances entre les
hommes et les femmes vous avez la parole
pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues les
dispositions concernant le de la santé
sexuelle et reproductive revê chacun le
comprendra une importance particulière
pour la délégation aux droits des femmes
notre rapport y a consacré 16
recommandations portant sur la
contraception la procréation
médicalement assisté l'IVG et la
profession de SAG femm s'agissant des
mineurs les filles comme les garçons
nous sommes convaincus que leur
information en matière de contraception
doit être renforcé il faut le marteler
en France
6,7 % des jeunes filles de 12 à 17 ans
ont déjà eu recours une fois à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
cette idée est insupportable car ces IVG
pourraent être évités
efficacement ce pourcentage dérangeant
est sans aucun doute le signe d'un échec
de l'information des jeunes en matière
de contraception et face à cet échec
notre responsabilité est collective
quelle que soit la bonne volonté des
parents la famille nous en sommes
convaincus n'est pas le meilleur endroit
pour aborder ces sujets délicats nous
avons donc souhaité renforcer la
sensibilisation des jeunes et de deux
manières d'abord en faisant en sorte que
les séances d'éducation à la sexualité
prévu dans l'enseignement secondaire
soit vraiment organisé au nombre de TR
TR par an ces séances se réduisent
souvent à une il faut les inscrire dans
les lettres de mission des chefs
d'établissement avec les moyens
nécessaires ensuite il faut absolument
favoriser l'accès des jeunes à une
consultation médical spécialement conçu
pour eux qui leur permettent de recevoir
toute l'information nécessaire en
matière de contraception et de poser
toutes les questions qu'il souhaitent à
une sagefemme ou à un médecin sans
d'être jugé et dans des conditions leur
garantissant pardon la plus totale
discrétion il pourrait se voir proposer
ce rendez-vous avec l'envoi de leur
carte Vitale il serait possible de
s'inspirer de ce qui est fait pour le
dépistage de certains cancers à partir
de 50 ans un amendement prévoit cette
visite nous comptons beaucoup sur le
soutien du Sénat et du gouvernement une
autre recommandation concrétisée par un
amendement vise dans un esprit
comparable à soutenir l'article 3 B
inséré par l'Assemblée nationale pour
permettre la meilleure information
possible sur la méthodes
contraceptives nous ne sommes pas
convaincus en effet que toutes les
femmes reçoivent toutes les informations
qu'elles sont en droit
d'attendre sur un sujet aux conséquences
importantes sur leur santé en revanche
la disposition miroire du projet de loi
figurant à l'article 31 et concernant
l'information sur les méthodes abortives
et le libre choix de la méthode
maintenue par la commission des affaires
sociales rejoint une recommandation de
la délégation et nous nous en
réjouissons s'agissant du parcours du
combattant des femmes engagées dans un
processus de PMA l'assistance médicale à
la
procréation aucune disposition ne les
protège nous leur proposerons donc par
un abandnement un un régime
d'autorisation d'absence analogue à
celui prévu pour les donneuses de vos
sites en en rappelant que plus de 23000
bébés naissent chaque année en France
dans ce cadre j'en viens aux
dispositions relatives à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse notre rapport
retrace les obstacles non négligeables
essentiellement d'ordre pratique qui
fragilisent en France l'accès à l'IVG et
sont à l'origine de disparités sensibles
entre les territoires depuis 10 ans plus
de 130 établissements de santé les
pratiquants ont été fermés pour les
femmes les délais d'attente de viennent
trop souvent excessifs nous préconisons
la mise en place dans chaque hôpital
public d'un centre pratiquement des IVG
et considérant qu'il faut garantir aux
professionnels les moyens nécessaires
dans le respect bien évidemment de la
clause de conscience notre délégation
présentera des amendements reprenant les
dispositions suivantes et regrette
qu'elles ne figurent plus dans le projet
de loi modifié par la commission des
affaires sociales l'extension au Centre
de santé de la pratique des IV IG
instrumental l'élaboration d'un plan
d'accès à l'IVG dans chaque région par
l'agence régionale de santé la
suppression du délai de réflexion d'une
semaine entre les deux consultations
préalables à l'IVG et l'extension aux
sages-femmes de la compétences en
matière d'IVG
médicamenteuse soutenons cette dernière
disposition car elle peut permettre
d'améliorer l'accès à l'IVG nous pensons
néanmoins que les femmes ne doivent pas
être conduites à y recourir par défaut
la délégation est très attachée au libre
choix des femmes il va falloir conclure
mon cher collègue oh s'agissant des
délais d'attente qui sont trop longs
nous pensons que la première demande
d'IVG devrait donc pouvoir être
recueillie par un autre professionnel
qu'un médecin ce sera l'objet d'un
amendement
euh donc enfin ce sera le dernier thème
de mon intervention le projet de loi
consacle le rôle grandissant des
sages-femmes auxquelles sont confié de
nouvelles responsabilités elles
deviennent des partenaires
indispensables de la santé et des femmes
parallèlement à la diminuion progressive
du nombre de gynécologues
médicaux je conclus voilà monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues l'essentiel des orientations
soutenues par la délégation et avec ma
collègue Françoise Laborde à l'égard de
ce projet qui comporte d'importantes
implications en matière de santé
sexuelle et reproductive il ne tient
qu'à vous mes chers collègues pour que
le texte que nous allons élaborer
ensemble en soit le reflet merci mes
chers
collègues
nous allons aborder maintenant la suite
de notre discussion
générale et la parole est à notre
collègue Catherine Génisson pour le
groupe socialiste et
républicain bonniversaire monsieur
Président vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre mes Mames les rapporteurs
monsieur le rapporteur Président mes
chers collègues moderniser notre système
de santé pour le rendre plus juste mieux
adapté aux réalités d'aujourd'hui tel
est le projet de loi dont nous devons
débattre ce dans un contexte paradoxe
très preignant l'excellence de notre
médecine qui se heurte aux inégalités
sociales territoriales de son
organisation la France peut
s'énorgueillir d'un excellent système de
santé que l'OMS estime comme un des
meilleurs classement qui reflète la
qualité des soins qu'offre la communauté
soignante à nos concitoyens notre pays
innove constamment et ouvre la voie en
matière de technologie nouvelles et à ce
titre notre pays est au 3e rang mondial
pour les brevets de robotique médicale à
tout que nous devons concrétiser de
façon plus offensive sur le plan
économique mais reconnaissant aussi que
l'organisation de notre système de santé
est trop cloisonnée voire crispée
hospital au centré même si sur le
terrain innovation transversalité
coopération
interprofessionnell se développe plus
que ce que relatent les les
organisations professionnelles et les
représentants syndicaux et quand les
jeune génération s'exprime avec exigence
mais esprit
d'ouverture le paradoxe réside donc dans
le fait que cette excellence médicale se
heurte aux inégalités sociales qui
perdurent à 100 ans vous l'avez cité
madame la ministre un ouvrier à une
espérance de vie de inférieure de 7 ans
à celle d'un cadre aux inégalités
territorial qui se creuse les déserts
médicaux sont très inégalement répartis
sur notre
territoire par ailleurs les besoins de
santé l'exercice des professionnels ont
évolué au regard du développement des
maladies chroniques du vieillissement de
la
population garantir l'égalité de nos
concitoyens au regard de la
modernisation de notre système de santé
des progrès de la recherche tel est la
colonne vertébrale du texte dont nous
allons
débattre trois piliers que je ne fais
qu'évoquer le premier la prévention
socle de notre système de santé vous
l'avez évoqué madame la ministre
prévention des maladies évitables des
pratiques addictives de l'alcoolisme du
tabagisme des problèmes de nutrition
concernant tant l'obésité excessive que
la très grande maigreur prise en compte
des engjeés de santé environnementale un
programme très complet structuré au cœur
duquel le public jeune est
particulièrement ciblé la lutte contre
le tabagisme alimentera nos débats ils
seront francs loyaux et
constructifs le deuxième pilier le
citoyen acteur de sa santé avec comme
premier correspondant son médecin
traitant le texte donne toute sa place
au soins primaires permettant grâce à la
mise en place de communautés
professionnelles de territoire de santé
aux acteurs de la médecine
ambulatoire d'être les initiateurs de
leur organisation ce qui lève le
reproche d'une organisation verticale à
l'initiative des agences régionales de
santé qui doivent néanmoins s'assurer de
leur bon
fonctionnement le tiers payant
généralisé sera mis en place une mesure
de justice une mesure technique aussi
qui doit permettre sans prendre de temps
administratif au médecin que l'argent ne
soit pas un obstacle àant l'entrée dans
le cabinet médical les médecins TR
soivent prendre en compte les
difficultés financières de leurs
patients nous aurons un grand débat je
l'espère à l'examen de l'article 18 que
nous rétablissons au nom de la justice
sociale et vous nous avez rassuré madame
la ministre sur l'application technique
de cette
disposition le service public
hospitalier est rétabli et donne toute
sa force au devoir que notre nation doit
à ses constituyens les groupements
hospitaliers de territoire les EHT
doivent optimiser l'offre h italière les
médecins et la communauté soignante
doivent prendre toute leur place dans la
constitution de ces groupements
hospitalier du territoire par ailleurs
les relations entre médecinees
hospitalière et libéral seront
approfondies autour de la notion du
parcours de soins des malades avec
obligation de la lettre de liaison à la
sortie de l'hôpital en
particulier enfin dans son trè pilier le
texte renforce la démocratie sanitaire
offre de nouveaux droits pour tous les
patients pour tous les citoyens avec la
mise en place des actions de
groupe la modernisation de l'Open Data
c'est-à-dire la possibilité de d'accéder
à des données anonymisées propice à la
recherche au progrès le droit à l'oubli
qui marque le respect de la dignité que
l'on droit que l'on doit au maladees
guérri du cancer aujourd'hui à d'autres
maladies dans l'avenir et ces sujets ont
donné lieu à des débats
constructifs mais notre groupe n'a pas
voté le texte à à l'issue des travaux de
notre
commission en effet si ces travaux de
préparation ont été de qualité et j'en
remercie le président rapporteur et les
rapporteurs le débat en commission a
souvent été contraint et
idéologique la majorité sénatoriale a
cassé les principes de justice et de
solidarité du texte issu de l'Assemblée
nationale le le débat était contraint le
débat était contraint quand bon nombre
des articles qui prêtent justement un
débat ont été simplement supprimé par la
majorité senetariale sans possibilité
d'entretenir des échanges ou quand sous
couvert de rationalisation de l'écriture
de la loi à l'article 1 par exemple et
nous en avons l'exemple à l'instant lors
de nos débats en commission des affaires
sociales on ne tient pas compte de
sujets comme handicap et santé égalité
femmes hommes et santé santé
environnementale et
santé le débat a également été
idéologique et je ne prendrai que deux
exemples le maintien des pôles de santé
qu'and sont proposé les communautés
professionnel de territoire de santé
pourtant largement négocié madame la
ministre vous l'avez dit parfois avec
tonicité d'ailleurs par les acteurs
eu-même et avec un accord obtenu par ces
mêmes acteurs de
santé
le débat également a été idéologique
quand vous avez refusé de supprimer le
délai de réflexion d'accès à l'IVG avec
l'argument que le sujet est un sujet
éthique le débat éthique c'est Madame
Simone veille qui l'a mené devant sa
majorité souvent conservatrice et
parfois odieuse et l'IVG a été voté
grâce à l'engagement remarquable de
Simon veille et au soutien de la gauche
aussi les mesures qui sont proposées
aujourd'hui ne sont que de simple
adaptation du dispositif pour le rendre
plus
efficace madame la ministre nous
connaissons votre engagement votre
détermination votre force de conviction
intangible aussi vous trouverez le
groupe socialiste à vos côtés dans un
débat franc et loyal quand le texte
reçoit majoritairement le soutien de nos
concitoyens au débat au-delà des débats
qui ont toute légitimité à s'exprimer
merci
merci Madame junisson la parole est
maintenant à madame Aline archambau pour
le groupe
écologiste monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales
mesames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers
collègues notre groupe écologiste a été
très déçu du sort réservé au textes venu
de l'Assemblée nationale lors de son
examen en commission certes nous sommes
satisfaits de l'adoption de notre
amendement demandant le renouvellement
automatique de l'aide à l'acquisition de
la complémentaire santé ACS pour les
bénéficiaires de laallocation adulte
handicapés et les bénéficiaires de
laallocation de solidarité aux personnes
âgées de même que nous sommes satisfaits
du maintien de l'interdiction du
bisphénol dans les jouets ou par exemple
la position responsable adoptée par la
commission sur l'expérimentation des
salles de consommation à moindre risque
le secret médical en prison ou encore
sur le dépistage rapide des mineurs mais
nous restons globalement très déçus du
fait que souscouvert de je cite
simplification de la loi les amendements
de suppression proposée par la majorité
sénatoriale porte sur le sens même
profond de cette loi
sur ces objectifs
fondamentaux la lutte contre les
inégalités sociales et pour l'accès au
droit la prévention la santé
environnementale l'égalité hommes-femme
la solidarité avec les personnes
handicapées ce sont pour notre groupe
comme pour d'autres je crois des
objectifs stratégiques fondamentaux qui
donnent ce sont ceux qui donnent du sens
à la loi et sur lesquels il nous paraît
absolument nécessaire que les
parlementaires aussi s'engagent sur
lesquels nous ne pouvons pas être muets
et je pense notamment aux articles 1 et
2 nous déplorons notamment la
disparition du concept d'exposome dans
la définition stratégique de la
politique de santé nous y reviendrons en
débat nous déplorons les reculs énormes
en matière de prévention avec la
suppression par exemple de dispositions
qui impacteront directement la jeunesse
la jeunesse étudiante la jeunesse
populaire les attaques règles contre
l'IVG d'autres collègues l'ont indiqué
sous le prétexte fallacieux que ces
dispositions devraient plutôt trouver
leur place dans une loi de bioéthique et
plus généralement la disparition du
principe d'égalité homme-femme rayé des
objectifs de notre politique de santé et
de toutes ces récurrences dans le texte
données sexuées dans les rapports des
médecins du travail et cetera nous
déplorons aussi notamment la suppression
de l'article 18 relatif à la
généralisation du tiers payant par pure
idéologie sans chercher à prendre en
compte les solutions techniques
nécessaires à une prise en main facile
par les médecins alors qu'en ce moment
même un groupe de travail est mis en
place et travaille justement pour donner
ces solutions techniques qui rassurent
les professionnels nous déploirons aussi
notamment la suppression du paquet
neutre j'y reviendrai mais ces regrets
ne nous découragent pas pour autant
notre groupe a résolument fait le choix
de continuer à jouer le jeu du travail
parlementaire en déposant plus de 200
amendements l'opinion publique est en
effet est en train de prendre conscience
souvent par l'expérience douloureuse de
la maladie de la réalité des alertes
lancées depuis des dizaines d'années sur
la santé publ plus de 80 % des dépenses
remboursées par l'Assurance Maladie en
France sont attribuables à des maladies
chroniques cancer diabète maladie
cardio-vasculaire allergie maladie
respiratoire malades dont l'apparition
et l'agrévation sont le plus souvent lié
à nos modes de vie et à la pollution de
notre environnement et si la politique
de santé ne s'adapte pas radicalement à
cette réalité le pire est à craindre
pour la santé de nos concitoyens et pour
la survie de notre assurance maladie il
faut par exemple avoir en tête le fait
que le surcout dû aux malades chronique
sur à peine 20 ans correspond à environ
quatre fois la dette de l'Assurance
Maladie 108 milliards et à deux fois
celui de la dette sociale totale 209
milliards d'euros c'est en partant de
ces considérations préoccupantes que mon
groupe a choisi de faire entendre lors
des débats ses propositions sur quatre
grands volets je serai évidemment très
brève mais je j'y reviendrai en débat
parce que le temps s'écoule premier
volet l'accès aux soins et au droit à la
lutte contre les inégalités sociales la
nécessité de simplifier les démarches
administratives pour soulager à la fois
les bénéficiaires les services de l'État
la lutte contre le nonreours les refus
de soins la généralisation du tiers
payant le droit à l'oubli deuxième volet
la santé environnementale d'où nos
amendements sur concernant les
perturbateurs endocriniens les parties
culfine la qualité de l'air intérieur
l'amiante le mercure dentaire les
pesticides les nanomatériaux par exemple
3ème volet la prévention renforcement de
l'étiquetage nutritionnel lutte contre
l'obésité soutien à la protection
maternelle et infantile et à la médecine
scolaire mobilisation contre le
tabagisme promotion du
sport santé au travail et je pourrais en
citer d'autres enfin 4è volet concernant
le secteur du
médicament nous proposons de poursuivre
intensifier la lutte contre les conflits
d'intérêts la transparence sur la
fixation des prix notamment la
prévention l'indemnisation des accidents
médicamenteux par
exemple madame la ministre vous l'avez
compris vous avez tout notre soutien sur
un certain nombre de points euh tout à
fait essentiel par ailleurs par ailleurs
nous espérons aussi que sur d'autres
points et il y a beaucoup d'autres
amendements que nous portons euh ces
amendements et ces propositions pourront
être débattu et et repris sa d'ailleurs
que certains collègues j'ai constaté
poussent des amendements qui vont dans
le même sens j'espère que nous pourrons
ici avoir un débat nous souhaitons que
l'examen en séance du projet de loi de
santé se fasse en bonne intelligence que
les questions de santé publique ne
fassent pas constamment l'objet de
posture partisane ou idéologique car le
débat doit être selon nous à la hauteur
des enjeux pour nos concitoyens je vous
remercie merci Madame chambau la parole
est à Madame madame Laurence Cohen pour
le groupe
CRC monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi était très attendu d'autant plus
que les politiques successives menées
depuis de nombreuses années n'ont pas
apporté de réponse satisfaisante aux
besoins en matière de santé pire elle
n'ont cessé d'affaiblir le système de
santé publique considérant la santé
comme un bien de consommation
malheureusement ce projet de loi est
loin de répondre aux enjeux actuels
notamment celui de combattre les
renoncements aux soins qui sont évalués
entre 25 à 30 %. je reconnais toutefois
le travail conséquent desélaboration de
ce projet de loi ainsi que celui mené
par les trois rapporteurs de notre
commission des affaires sociales
notamment au travers des nombreuses
heures d'audition réalisé permettez-moi
de commencer par souligner les
dispositions qui au groupe CRC nous
paraissent tout à fait POS
j'entends par là les dispositions qui
figurent encore dans ce texte celles qui
n'ont pas été supprimées par la majorité
sénatoriale en commission je pense
notamment au titre premier qui vise à
renforcer la prévention l'accès à la
contraception d'urgence pour les élèves
du second degré la lutte contre
l'alcoolisation massive des jeunes la
lutte contre le tabagisme je ne peux pas
détailler ces mesures qui si elles sont
véritablement mises en place avec les
moyens afférents porteront leur fruit je
tiens également exprimer ma grande
satisfaction qu'au-delà des clivages
politiques une majorité se soit dégagée
du moins en commission pour soutenir
l'expérimentation de celle de
consommation à moindre risque c'est un
projet que j'ai beaucoup soutenu
convaincu de son utilité sanitaire dans
une optique de réduction des risques et
des dommages pour les usagers de drogue
je note enfin avec intérêt la volonté de
reconnaître la place et le rôle des
centres de santé dans notre système de
soins assez souvent méconnu voire déval
valoriser les centres de santé
représentent au contraire un modèle
innovant prenant en compte à la fois les
attentes exprimées notamment par de
jeunes professionnels en matière de
travail d'équipe et qui répond aux
besoins du plus grand nombre pas de
dépassement d'honoraires tiers payant et
cetera je salue donc cette avancée qui
pour se concrétiser appelle elle aussi
l'apport de moyens conséquent j'en viens
à présent au dispositions qui nous
paraissaient importantes mais qui ont
été supprimées par la droite en
commission affaires sociales je pass sur
cette nouvelle mode de supprimer
systématiquement toute demande de
rapport l'article 40 de notre
Constitution est déjà fort contraignant
pour l'initiative parlementaire mais si
à présent les rapports sont bannis cela
devient compliqué la généralisation du
tiers payant a été vivement attaquée
notamment sous le prétexte d'un surcooi
de travail pour les médecins et d'une
difficulté de mise en place de ce
système sans négliger ce problème nous
soutenons cette mesure car elle peut
aider un certain nombre de patients mais
nous pensons qu'elle ne répond pas au
renoncement aux soins apporte le tiers
payant concernant les lunettes les
prothèses dentaires ou auditives que la
sécurité sociale ne ne rembourse pas oui
ridiculement pour mon groupe la mesure
véritablement juste capable de faire
reculer les renoncements aux soins donc
les inégalités et la prise en charge à
100 %. c'est possible et c'est un combat
que nous aurions souhaité mener avec
vous Madame la Ministre mais il n'est
pas trop tard l'une des autres
suppressions les plus emblématiques à
nos yeux c'est celle de l'article 17 bis
qui visisait à suprimer le délai de
réflexion pour l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse la droite a supprimé cet
article au motif que la discussion
devait se faire dans le cadre de la loi
sur la bioéthique comment parler de
bioéthique en 2015 pour un droit gagné
par la lutte des femmes et vootter en
1975 grâce au courage de Madame veille
de même la majorité sénatoriale a
supprimé une disposition symbolique en
terme d'égalité des droits de non
discrimination à savoir l'article 7 bis
qui autorisait enfin les les personnes
homosexuelles à donneré leur sang je ne
vais pas lancer le débat ici mais pour
nous il est essentiel que cette
discrimination cesse et que seul la
sécurité sanitaire soit le critère
dominant le même appliqué à chacun j'en
viens enfin à l'essence même du texte
madame la ministre sa philosophie
générale qui n'a pas réussi à nous
convaincre alors que vous étiez à juste
titre tout comme l'ensemble de votre
groupe assez critique sur le contenu et
le tournant marchand de la loi
HPST euh notamment au niveau du monde
hospitalier son organisation j'avoue
avoir du mal à saisir pourquoi en tant
que ministre vous n'avez pas fait le
choix de rompre avec cette précédente
loi nous constatons pourtant au
quotidien les désastres qu'elle a
engendré l'hôpital public a été
transformé en entreprise avec un
fonctionnement qui ne lui est absolument
pas adapté pourquoi ne pas revenir sur
la loi HPST pourquoi continuer à
accorder de tels pouvoirs au directeurs
d'Ars ces super préfet sanitair comme
nous les avions appelés à l'époque vous
vantez à juste titre la démocratie
sanitaire mais le conseil de
surveillance remplace toujours le
conseil d'administration et le modèle de
décision verticale du ministère au
directeurs d'Ars en passant par le
directeur d'hôpital reste en vigueur
avec une logique financière
administrative qui prend le dessus sur
la logique médicale de même nous sommes
inquiets de ces groupements hospitaliers
de territoire ght qui ne nous
apparaissent que comme une nouvelle
occasion de fusionner donc de fermer des
établissements des services des lits
alors qu'aujourd'hui on compte 1200 1300
hôpitaux il serait question de
constituer 100 gchté où est le lien de
proximité où est la volonté de réduire
les inégalités territoriales alors que
vous avez citer monsieur vigneron dans
votre propos où est la démocratie
sanitaire après les mégapoles de la loi
NRE voici les méga hôpitaux une façon
sans doute de légitimer toujours un peu
plus le privé on ne sent pas dans le
projet de loi c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire la prise de conscience que
le monde de l'hôpital public va mal
souffre des politiques de réduction
menées depuis des années effectiv en
flux tendu offre de soin en diminution
dé laai trop long urgence asphyié et je
ne parle pas de la psychiatrie car le
temps mécé mais il y aurait beaucoup à
dire on y reviendra dans le débat alors
évidemment on va me répondre que les
budgets sont contraints et qu'il n'est
guerre possible de faire autrement d'où
d'ailleurs sans doute les 3 milliards
d'euros en moins pour les hôpitaux
aggravant encore un peu plus leur
situation désastreuse mais madame la
ministre nous avons d'autres
propositions de financement qui peuvent
redonner du souffle et vigueur à une
politique de santé publi digne de ce nom
une politique qui s'appuie notamment sur
une médecine de ville redynamisée
supprimons la T2A ce système inadapté et
inefficace les franchises et les
forfaits hospitaliers les exonérations
de cotisation patronnale qui privent
notre protection sociale 2 milliards
d'euros mettons en place une nouvelle
cotisation sur les revenus financiers
des entreprises sur une base de 317,9
milliards d'euros en 2010 on pourrait
dégager en les soumettant au taux actuel
de la cotisation patronale 41 milliards
pour la maladie 26 milliards pour la
retraite 16 milliards pour la famille
alors voilà quelques propositions qu'il
faudrait prendre en compte madame la
ministre les quelques avancées de ce
texte ne seront que de l'affichage tant
que le carcan financier imposé à
l'ensemble des établissements de santé
sera la boussole du gouvernement
l'attitude de notre groupe tout au long
du débat sera évidemment de modifier cet
état de faê et de construire des
amendements qui seront en mesure de
répondre à une vraie politique de santé
ambitieuse qui fasse réellement reculer
les inégalités une politique de santé
pour toutes et tous sur l'ensemble du
territoire merci la parole est à
Monsieur Gilbert Barbier pour le groupe
RDSE monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre messieurs
monsieurs et mesdames les rapporteurs
président de la commission mes chers
collègues è en janvier dernier mon
groupe politique a lancé le débat autour
d'une question assez basique j'en
conviens la médecine française éelle
toujours la meilleure du monde ce débat
certes limité dans le temps s'est révélé
cependant très intéressant
malheureusement on n'avait pas pu y
assister madame la ministre mais madame
ségolen
neeville cégoline Neville l'a clôturé en
ces termes le gouvernement compte sur le
Parlement et le Sénat en particulier
pour enrichir et améliorer le projet de
loi de santé défendu par Madame Thouret
alors nous y sommes nous sommes là
Madame le Ministre pour débattre de ce
dossier fort complexe de l'adaptation de
notre système de santé aux évolutions de
la société et de la science il me semble
cependant que cette discussion ne
s'ouvre pas sous les meilleurs auspices
et à ce stade je ferai simplement part
de quelques observation générale qui
m'inquiète par rapport à cette volonté
de dialogue la première observation
porte sur la méthode parlementaire
retenue à savoir la procédure accélérée
c'est faire fi du Parlement de lui
demander d'expédier un texte aussi dense
aussi divers aussi conséquent dans son
application en une seule navette un
texte qui des 57 articles que vous avez
présenté est passé à 209 à l'Assemblée
nationale un texte qui à mes yeux s'il
devait en rester là porterait une
atteinte gravissime à notre système même
si celui-ci se doit d'être adapté à
l'évolution de la médecine
cette évolution ne peut se faire de
cette manière ma deuxème observation
porte également sur un problème de forme
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour de cette
session extraordinaire qui a nécessité
en commission travail pied au plancher à
la fin juillet ne peut-être considéré
comme satisfaisant d'autres l'ont relevé
de plus le temps de débat en séance
publique est bien limité étaler sur de
semaines entrecoupé d'une semaine
d'interruption et de débat cert urgent
et nécessaire
mais qui renvoie notre discussion sur ce
dossier au second plan il faut bien
reconnaître le temps consacré à l'étude
des 1200 amendements déposés ne sera
guerre supérieur à 35 he soit plus de 30
amendements à l'heure monsieur le
Président il faudra être très
vigilant ce n'est pas crédible ce n'est
pas sérieux cela va encore aggraver
l'antiparlementarisme dans l'air du
temps et plus particulièrement en
direction de notre assemblée dont on
sait bien qu'il est toujours dans le
viseur du gouvernement ma troisème
observation porte encore sur la forme et
la manière dont a été élaboré ce projet
pour avoir rencontré les représentants
de beaucoup de professions concernées
leur première réflexion par opposition à
ce que vous avez dit Madame le Ministre
porte sur l'absence de concertation à
priori voire même de simples
consultations des inéressés d'où un flot
de demande de remarques probablement pas
toute justifié d'ailleurs mais qui
méritait au moins une écoute une
explication ind dialogue et ceci est
particulièrement flagrant avec le
représentant du corps médical et votre
absence ce weekend au congrès de la CSMF
a été particulièrement marqué alors que
ce syndicat ne passe pas pour être le
plus hostile à vos idées et j'en viens
au fond ce projet est dominé par votre
cheval de bataille votre hobbyors le
tiers payant
généralisé par cette proposition vous
espérez certainement mettre l'opinion
publique derrière vous les gratuit pour
tous quel auè quel conquête sociale je
pense au contraire que nos concitoyens
aspirent avant tout à une prise en
charge de leur maladie de la meilleure
façon le malade recherche l'excellence
dans le soins dont il a besoin et les
moyens de communication modern lui
permettent aujourd'hui de rechercher
cette optimisation légitime ce n'est pas
cette gratuité déguisée qui lui
apportera la certitude pour moi une des
principales inégalités la ibilité ou non
d'accéder aux avancées les plus
performantes de la spécialité concernée
par la maladie du patient les
contingences matérielles sont
importantes mais ce n'est pas un critère
déterminant ce TPG puisqu'il faut
l'appeler comme cela aura permis au
gouvernement le très rare exploit de
réunir par le rejet de cette disposition
tous les organes représentatifs de la
profession médicale cette performance
mérite quand même d'être soulignée mais
derrière cette obstination
sur ce point que se cache-t-il sinon une
volonté de mettre à bas la médecine
libérale qui depuis plus d'un siècle a
fait de la médecine française un système
performant efficace humaniste en
instaurant le dialogue singulier médecin
patient c'est la relation indispensable
pour une confiance mutuelle à partir
d'un maître mot le mot liberté liberté
du soignant liberté du soigner
l'adjectif libéral vient bien de liberté
la médecine libérale n'est rien d'autre
que l'exercice de cette liberté ce que
nos citoyens doivent comprendre c'est
qu'en portant atteinte à la liberté de
l'un on fait disparaître la liberté de
l'autre et la liberté du soignant est
fondamentale dans la recherche de
l'excellence revendiqué par le soignier
votre projet par le biais du TPG vise à
enfermer dans un carcan étatique au nom
d'un égalitarisme illusoire la
dispensation des soins mais conduira
Infiné à sa
paupérisation les expériences de
médecine étatisée conduite dans un
certain nombre de pays ont bien démontré
la limite du système que la médecine
libérale ambulatoire ou hospitalière a à
évoluer personne n'en doute et notamment
pas par l'implication du citoyen dans
son parcours de santé mais c'est un par
un dialogue permanent qu'une réforme
efficace peut aboutir votre obstination
sur ce point va occulter le reste du
projet qui comporte quelques avancées
intéressantes j'en conviens en matière
de prévention les intentions sont bonnes
généreuses il serait d'ailleurs soitable
de scinder les objectifs généraux des
priorités sachant que tout ne peut pas
se faire en même temps en raison de la
situation financière tant de la sécurité
sociale que des finances de l'État
soyons réaliste sur ce point pour le
reste comme pour certaines réformes
antérieure je ne vois pas poindre les
mesures qui s'avèerent nécessaires et
urgentes pour modernis
notamment l'hospitalisation publique
celle-ci en est encore sur les bases de
la loi de
1970 voire de celle de 1958 concernant
les CHU ces doigts ont lu leur mérite
mais sont pour une grande part obsolète
par rapport à l'évolution des pratique
médical les autres sujets je passe très
vite qui FCH sont passer sous silence le
numérus closus la validation des
connaissances de certains praticiens
exerçant dans les hôpitaux généraux la
surcapacité hospitalière l'obsolescence
de certains un plateau technique l'échec
de la CCAM le peu d'efficacité du rospre
et bien d'autre au cours de ces débats
mes collègues du groupe RDSE moi-même
dans notre diversité essaierons de vous
aider à bâtir une loi qui puisse
répondre à une seule question mieux
prévenir mieux soigner et mieux gérer le
formidable potentiel humain que
représente le monde de la santé dans
notre pays je vous remerci merci la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur David
rachelin pour le groupe des non inscrits
monsieur le Président Madame la
ministrre mes chers collègues si le
système de santé français fait notre
fierté c'est davantage par les hommes et
les femmes qui œuvrent chaque jour au
service des autres avec dévouement voire
abnégation auquel il convient de rendre
ici hommage que par son organisation et
son financement ce projet de loi comme
d'habitude présenté comme ambitieux
notamment dans sa nouvelle dénomination
comporte dans la version sortie de
l'Assemblée nationale des mesures
organisationnelles correspondant bien à
l'intitulé euh du texte mais qui ont été
passablement chahutés par une grande
partie des professionnels de santé
quelques mesures d'ordre sanitaire et
bien sûr comme tout bon projet de loi
socialiste un certain nombre de mesures
idéologiques je me félicite que le
passage du texte en commission est
permis de sortir la plupart de ces
mesures idéologiques qui ne modernisent
en rien notre système de santé mais qui
au contraire l'enferme dans une
étatisation grandissante où ces mesures
qui accentuent la perte de repère moral
de notre société en particulier pour sa
jeunesse mais je me rassure ce sont les
derniers soubressau de 68 ARS dieu merci
sur le déclin laffonte d'une grande
partie du monde médical sur ce projet de
loi marque Madame le Ministre le
caractère idéolog idéologue idéologique
même de vos réformes or il est
impensable d'agir sur notre système de
santé sans une réelle concertation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs en premier chef
ceux qui œuvrent chaque jour auprès des
malades je suis content que les 68 AR ce
soi reconnus notre système de santé doit
reposer sur une juste
répartition entre le secteur public et
le secteur privé entre les hôpitaux les
cliniques et les libéraux qu'ils soient
médecins infirmiers ou paramédicaux il
doit également reposer j'insiste
fortement sur ce point sur une
responsabilisation du patient du patient
et plus largement de tous les
bénéficiaires la santé a un coût et bien
que ce soit l'état qui paye ça ne coûte
pas rien les déficits de notre système
de santé diminueront d'abord par une
prise de conscience collective et par
une responsabilisation de chacun il est
aujourd'hui grand le risque à force de
générosité pour tous avec l'argent des
Français et qu'à force d'accepter un
véritable gaspillage des prestations de
santé notre système de santé dont nous
sommes si fiers s'effondre et je doute
que la généralisation du du tiers payant
au-delà de la difficulté technique dans
sa mise en œuvre soit un moyen de
responsabiliser les patients le fait
d'avancer les frais médicaux est un
moyen de prendre conscience de leurs
coût il est étonnant que d'ailleurs que
ceux qui rechignent à avancer les
quelques euros d'une consultation soit
souvent ceux qui possèdent le dernier
téléphone à la mode quand ça n'est pas
la dernière BMW à la mode car ça arrive
aussi parfois les personnes souffrant de
précarité étant déjà assuré de
bénéficier du du tiers payant nous
connaissons votre propension à
infantiliser les concitoyens et à
imposer dans leur vie une omniprésence
de l'État mais nous nous croyons à la
responsabilisation de chacun il est
temps particulièrement dans le domaine
de la santé de laiss nos concitoyens
redevenir pleinement adultes et de se
prendre en main ce qui n'exclut en rien
le principe de solidarité évidemment en
outre je ne vois pas dans ce projet de
loi de mesures visant à lutter contre la
fraude qui nous le savons tous est un
fléau pour les finances de notre système
de
santé notre système de santé j'en
termine est aujourd'hui déficitaire or
pour restaurer l'équilibre des comptes
sociaux il me semble nécessaire de
donner la priorité aux Français cela
pourrait commencer par l'installation
d'un délai de carence d'un an de
résidence et de cotisation continue en
en France avant de bénéficier de tous
les avantages de la sécurité sociale ou
encore par une ame réservée au seul cas
d'urgence vital mais également par la
récupération des sommes dues par
d'autres États à nos caisses je je
conclus le roi d'Arabie Saoudite entre
de bains sur nos plages privatisées
gardé et masculiniser a-t-il déjà Madame
le Ministre rembourser les millions que
son pays nous doit ce n'est que à
travers la responsabilisation et la
priorité accordé à nos à nos propres
compatriotes que nous parviendrons à
préserver et à moderniser notre système
de santé
merci la parole est maintenant à Madame
Corine Ambert pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales et rapporteurs
mesdames les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues j'aimerais tout d'abord avoir
quelques mots d'amitié de soutien à
l'égard de notre collègue René Paul
Savari qui aurait dû également
intervenir à la tribune en tant
qu'orateur du groupe cet après-midi mais
qui a été malheureusement accidenté il y
a quelques jours je lui souhaite bien
sûr un prompte et très très bon
rétablissement son travail et son
engagement dans la préparation de
l'examen du projet de loi de santé ont
été indispensables tant pour la
commission des affaires sociales que
pour notre groupe
ou on peut avoir une penser pour
lui il va bien et tant mieux je l'ai
tenu au courant de mon projet
d'intervention je tenais en effet à
l'associé et qu'il puisse à travers moi
s'exprimer il y a donc un peu de René
Paul Savari dans les propos que je vais
tenir devant vous cet
après-midi la Haute Assemblée s'apprête
donc à discuter d'un projet de loi qui
sort tout juste d'une convalescence
estivale
lors de son examen en juillet dernier
par les commissaires aux affaires
sociales la majorité sénatoriale s'est
en effet employé à soigner un grand
corps malade et je salue
l'investissement essentiel de nos trois
rapporteurs le président Milon et les
sénatrices de roche et
douanau devenu une habitude pour ce
gouvernement madame la ministre le texte
présenté est un véritable inventaire où
se mêent à la fois dispositif de
prévention de santé publique et de
formation touchant aux professions aux
missions aux établissements et aux
structures de santé c'est un arsenal qui
n'a de modernisation du système que le
titre dans les faet il étatise et
bureaucratise l'existant et je ne
voudrais pas qu'il devienne un épais
brouillard nocif pour notre système de
santé l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé s'est élevé unanimement contre les
dispositions initiales cela provoqué un
tolé des manifestations massives et tous
les acteurs concernés par cette réforme
ont tu un sentiment de mépris face à
votre autisme car ce n'est qu'après le
dépôt du texte à l'Assemblée nationale
que les concertation ont eu lieu la
majorité sénatoriale a donc pris ses
responsabilités et s'est engagé dans un
processus de réécriture du projet de loi
afin qu'il n'oppose pas mais qu'il
rassemble et
rationalise sur l'aspect prévention et
promotion de la santé ce texte aborde
l'accès des jeunes à la contraception
d'urgence la lutte contre la
consommation excessive d'alcool la
promotion d'une alimentation équilibrée
mais aussi la lutte contre la maigreur
excessive la lutte contre le tabac et
vous proposz d'expérimenter ce que l'on
appelle communément des salles de shoot
certaines de ces dispositions ne nous
posent pas de problème cependant
concernant les articles relatifs aux
actions de promotion de la santé en
milieu scolaire ils ne permettent aucun
progrès concret en la matière les textes
législativs et réglementaires en vigueur
donne déjà une double mission à l'école
celle de suivre l'état de santé des
élèves et celle de contribuer à leur
éducation à la santé on ne voit donc pas
qu'el autre objectif que l'affichage
politique est poursuivi par cette
nouvelle disposition se superposant les
unes aux autres
il en va de même pour la prohibition de
la publicité concernant l'abus d'alcool
l'amendement porté par notre collègue
gérard César sénateur de la girironde au
cours de l'examen du projet de loi sur
la croissance et l'activité amendement
qui sera à nouveau discuté à l'occasion
de l'examen de ce texte ne vise
absolument pas à remettre en cause la
loi Évin ni à contester l'excès de la
consommation d'alcool notamment chez les
jeunes concernant les dispositions
relatives à la nutrition les mesures
peuvent être discutables je prends je
prends l'exemple des symboles des
indicateurs de couleur pour les denrées
alimentaires deviendra-t-on obèse
délibérément en ne consommant que des
produits rouges ou serons-nous en pleine
santé en ne consommant que du verre si
l'intention est louable cela restera un
indicateur et son effet en terme de
lutte contre l'obésité sera très
marginale une couleur ne change pas un
comportement même si elle peut y
contribuer Enfin il y a lieu de rappeler
ici qu'il ne faut aucunement confondre
maigreur et anorxie dans les
dispositions concernant le manquina
l'instauration d'un critère unique comme
celui de l'indice de masse corporelle
peut paraître inefficace nous allons
donc vous proposer d'avoir recours à la
médecine du travail afin de poser un
regard expert et régulier sur les
professionnels de la
mode venons-on à votre projet de paquet
neutre bien évidemment tout le monde est
bien conscient de la nocivité du tabac
et nul ne peut ignorer ses effets
directs et néfastes sur la santé
cependant est-il réellement pertinent
d'instaurer le paquet neutre alors même
que la directive européenne encadre et
contra déjà les fabricants à de
nouvelles normes concernant les
emballages de cigarettes bien évidemment
non d'autant plus que cette mesure
accentuera deux effets néfaste
premièrement encourager l'achat des
cigarettes aux frontières ou au marché
noir et deuxièmement aggraver les
difficultés pour les buralis qui
constitue aujourd'hui l'un des derniers
réseaux de commerçants d'une telle
dimension niveau national et que nous
devrons accompagner dans l'évolution de
leur
profession oui fumz-tu madame la minist
bien sûr mais mal réformé asphyxie pour
pourquoi s'inscrire dans une démarche de
surtransposition des directives
européennes nous avons fait le choix et
nous l'assumons de supprimer le paquet
neutre au profit du texte européen qui
viendra recouvrir le paquet de messages
dissuasif à 65 % au lieu de 40 %
présentement le vrai courage aurait été
peut-être d'aborder la problématique de
l'uniformisation européenne des tarifs
du tabac c'est aussi en menant une
politique de prévention globale à
l'échelle européenne que nous pourrons
obtenir des résultats tangibles et non
en sanctionnant àrance à l'chelle
nationale concernant les salles de
consommation à moindre risque dite salle
de shoot la commission des affaires
sociales a souhaité maintenir leur
expérimentation nous vous proposerons
d'informer et d'associer les maires en
amont des décisions d'expérimentation
celle-ci nexcluant pas le contrôle nous
ferons preuve d'une extrême vigilance
quant au résultats des créations de ces
espaces qui devront être très
encadrés la grande variété des sujets
abordés par le texte du Gouvernement est
aussi symbolisé par des mesures
notamment relatives à l'interruption
volontaire de Gross s l'IVG cela a été
largement évoqué déjà aussi nous avons
constaté non sans surprise l'insertion
de la suppression du délai de réflexion
de 7 jours pour une
IVG la possibilité donneré aux Centre de
santé de pratiquer des IVG chirurgicales
la compétence donné au sage-femme pour
la réalisation des IVG médicamenteuses
et la réforme du don d'organe si nous ne
contestons pas l'intérêt de certains de
ces mesures elle mériterait en effet un
large débat ces dispositions non'ont à
notre avis pas leur place au sein de ce
projet de loi qui prétend moderniser
notre système de santé elles auraient
davantage leur place dans une loi
bioéthique venonson à présent au passage
en force à l'étatisation systématisée
érigeeant un véritable socle idéologique
et dogmatique de cette réforme les
agences régionales de santé symbolisent
cette orientation et sont promises à un
bel avenir peut-être même une promotion
certaine deviendront-elles demain des
préfecture régionale de santé ainsi les
S deviennent des superstructures
bureaucratiques dont le but essentiel et
si de contrôler d'imposer les cadres
d'exercice de la médecine libérale et
hospitalière nous sommes bien entendu
farouchement opposés à toute perte de
quelques degrés soit-elle de liberté
cette liberté est une garantie de
qualité et de continuité tant pour les
soins que pour le suivi des patients
opposer sans cesse le secteur public au
secteur privé est une erreur ils sont
complémentaires et doivent interagir
pour être
efficient la Commission propose donc de
redonner aux établissements privés la
possibilité d'effectuer des missions de
services
publics vous dites madame la ministre
que la désertification médicale en
milieu rural est aujourd'hui un sujet
prioritaire vous avez raison elle est
aussi parfois en secteur urbain
plusieurs facteurs conduisent à cet état
de fait c'est une vraie question
d'aménagement du territoire et que
proposez-vous la suppression des pôles
de santé pour les remplacer par des
communautés professionnelles de santé la
Commission et la majorité sénatoriale
ont réintroduit les pôles de santé
véritables outils de coopération nous
avons souhaité les renforcer ils
fonctionneront d'autant mieux que ce
seront des projets élaborés par les
professionnels eux-mêmes il est
indispensable d'améliorer l'offre de
soins à partir de ce dispositif et
souvenez-vous que ce ne sont ni les murs
ni les dispositifs qui soignent ce sont
les professionnels de
santé je tiens également à soutenir la
mesure adoptée par notre commission sur
proposition des rapporteurs relative à
l'obligation de négocier dans le cadre
de la convention médicale autour de
l'installation des médecin en zone dite
sous-doté enfin nous souhaitons que le
contrat d'engagement de service public
destiné aux étudiants et aux interne
soit développé mieux connu et plus
attractifs toutes ces mesures montrent
qu'il est possible de concilier liberté
d'installation et prise en compte des
besoins des territoires mais surtout des
patients ainsi la liberté du patient
doit être possible et préservée la
garantie d'être soigné par un patricien
qui ne soit pas un praticien commis
d'office est primordiale la au soins ne
doit pas être concentré et contraint
doit être avant tout structuré pour être
performant vient un amendement de notre
rapporteur Catherine de roche la
Commission a également fait le choix de
préserver l'activité des médecins
libéraux et notamment celle des
associations de permanence des soins
dans l'organisation de la permanence des
soins ambulatoires en effet cette
mission de service public est assurée
par les médecins libéraux en
collaboration avec les établissements de
santé mais certaines ARS avaient décid
de supprimer la permanence des soins
ambulatoires entre minuit et 8h du matin
ce qui allait à l'encontre du dispositif
prévu quant à la création des
groupements hospitaliers de territoire
la Commission les a maintenus tout en
modifiant le paradigme initial le projet
médical doit être partagé entre les
professionnels et non être la résultante
d'une décision imposée par l'unique
volonté de l'agence régionale de santé
fait une éd qui peut nous inciter à la
vigilance concernant cette mesure les
agences régionales de santé reçoivent
depuis janvier 2015 les injonctions pour
mettre en place des groupements
hospitaliers de territoire sans projet
médical préalable alors que la loi n'est
même pas voter bon sens de
l'anticipation et votre volonté de
rationaliser les coûts ce que nous
pouvons comprendre et ce que nous
partageons tout en maintenant des
services adaptés aux soins ne doit pas
vous conduire à inverser les rôles les
commissaires ont également fait le choix
de valoriser au sein du projet de loi
les professionnels de la santé en
rétablissement par exemple l'ordre
infirmier un ordre et gar de l'éthique
d'une profession et de ces bonnes
pratiques qui pourraient s'en
plaindre en tant que phacienne
d'officine j'approuve les dispositions
visant à innover pour la qualité des
bonnes pratiques le bon usage du
médicament et la sécurité des soins je
rappellerai que la loi de répartition
qui régit notre installation permet un
aménagement du territoire remarquable
garant de la proximité mais que ce
réseau devient fragile je souhaite aussi
vous pardon je souhaite aussi vous
appeler à une grande vigilance madame la
ministre concernant le développement de
la pharmacie numérique il n'y a pas lieu
d'aller au-delà de ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui un développement trop
important et mal encré serait une porte
ouverte dans notre pays à la mise sur le
marché de faux médicaments c'est un fléo
mondial que vous n'ignorez pas et qui
est aujourd'hui plus rémunérateur que le
trafic de
drogue enfin comment évoquer ce projet
de loi sans parler de la généralisation
du tiers
payant c'est une fausse bonne idée une
promesse veine un choix de facilité non
de responsabilité une perte de
conscience du coup réel de la santé oui
nous souhaitons maintenir ce dispositif
pour les patients les plus fragiles mais
il est totalement déraisonnable de
généraliser ce
mécanisme dans le cadre du parcours de
soins la loi oublie les nouvelles
technologies liées à la télémédecine ou
à la télétransmission des examens qu'il
faut encadrer c'est aussi par ces voies
nouvelles de l'innovation technologique
que l'on pourra tendre vers l'équité de
la prise en charge des
patients on nous dit qu'il n'y a jamais
eu autant de médecins mais qu'il serait
mal réparti c'est donc bien
l'organisation qu'il faudrait revoir
la formation des médecins n'est pas
toujours en adéquation avec les besoins
de la population et des territoires plus
on technocratise l'organisation plus on
aura besoin de médecin c'est la c'est la
conséquence évidente de cette
loi les économistes disent volontiers
que la médecine à l'acte produit trop
d'actes et que la médecine salariée n'en
produit pas assez cette loi va dans le
sens d'une médecine salariée ce qui veut
bien dire qu'il faudra former davantage
de médecin et je me joins à la pensée de
notre collègue René Paul Savari
intervenu de nombreuses fois sur ce
sujet
étatiser la médecine conduit
inévitablement à augmenter le numérus
clausus vous l'avez compris madame la
ministre en ce qui nous concerne en ce
qui concerne notre groupe nous sommes
davantage et nous défendons un maintien
de la médecine libérale avec une
complémentarité du secteur privé et du
secteur public et une liberté
d'initiative en ce qui concerne le coût
de la santé cette loi ne règle rien le
problème économique à savoir que la
sécurité sociale est en déficit
structurel et que les complémentaires
sont excédentaire le tiers payant
généralisé ne fera qu'accroître ce
différentiel entre secteur déficitaire
et secteur excédentaire madame la
ministre à terme vous remettez en cause
le libre choix du patient puisque
derrière ce texte le parcours de soins
sera organisé par ceux qui auront le
pouvoir financier à savoir les
complémentaires la liberté c'est avant
tout le choix de leurs médecins pour les
patients et le choix de leur
installation pour les médecins avec
toutes ces remises en cause les patients
seront pénalisés et les médecins
démotivés ce sera une atteinte au choix
une atteinte à la liberté du patient
donc l'amplification d'une médecine à
deux vitesses et je pense que là vous
jouez un jeu
dangereuxes chers collègues ce projet de
loi hospitalo centré que nous apprêtons
à discuter au-delà du fait qu'il ne
règle en rien les problèmes de santé qui
nous préoccupent tous est un véritable
Fourtout qui ne propose aucune
modernisation ni aux patients ni aux
professionnels de santé souvenez-vous de
cette question que se posait déjà
Socrate en son temps existe-t-il pour
l'homme un bien plus précieux que la
santé à ce titre nous ne pouvons pas
laisser passer ces mesures insidieuses
qui bouvceraiit profondément notre
système de santé pour constater dans
quelques années qu'il serait trop tard
pour sauver la médecine libéral je n'ose
imaginer les meilleurs spécialistes
partis à l'étranger un secteur public
hospitalier vidé de ses meilleurs
éléments et un secteur privé dans
ces
initiatives c'est bon j'ai bientôt fini
rassurez-vous madame la ministre ne
cassez pas la motivation des
professionnels de santé il n'exerce pas
un métier par défaut ilexerce avec
dévouement avec passion et dans
l'intérêt de leurs patients
souvenez-vous aussi de ce que tous les
étudiants en santé ont entendu au cours
de leurs études surtout et d'abord ne
pas nuire s'il vous plaît ne nuisez pas
notre système de santé que beaucoup de
pays nous envie je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur gérardoch
pour leoup groupe udi
UC monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues au nom du
groupe uduc j'aimerais aborder cette
discussion de façon très positive qu'à
l'organisation de la santé et l'affaire
de nous tous le test qui nous est soumis
est le fruit de un véritable travail de
colégislation c'est donc dans une
optique de collaboration constructive
entre le gouvernement et le Parlement
que nous l'envisageons de fait pour
l'heure chaque étape de la navette
législative a apporté sa pierre à
l'édifice et nous espérons bien Madame
le Ministre pouvoir y ajouter la notre
au cours de cette lecture cette loi de
santé était attendue attendue par les
professionnels par les patients plus
généralement par l'ensemble des citoyens
et on en connaît les raisons on observe
aujourd'hui une discordance entre la
qualité des services prodigués et les
difficultés d' accès aux soins dans les
territoires de plus la société a changé
elle a vieilli alors qu'en plus des
problèmes spécifiquement liés à la santé
des jeunes se son ont fait jour enfin il
faut pas oublier le problème lancinant
du coût de la santé ce que l'on
attendait était donc une loi cadre qui
modernise le système principalement dans
trois directions le développement de la
prévention l'amélioration de
l'accessibilité aux soins et la
simplification globale du parcours de
soins ce sont bien les thèmes qui sont
abordés par le projet gouvernemental ils
ne sont donc pas éludés ces orientations
générales sont louables mais émaillés de
dispositions fortement contestées sur
lesquelles nous reviendrons bien sûr au
fil de nos longs débats et peut-être de
nos très longs débats on peut même se
demander légitimement si certains des
sujets abordés n'aurait pas dû faire
l'objet de loi à part entière plutôt que
d'être ainsi survolé au cours d'un
amendement tant il nous paraisse
important sur cette base nos collègues
députés sont parés du texte pour le
faire quadrupler de volume pour être
honnête comment les emblammer on ne peut
pas d'un côté défendre l'initiative
parlementaire et de l'autre la fustiger
lorsqu'elle trouve à s'exprimer mais
c'est ce qui a donné à cette cadre des
aires de loi un peu fortout à ce stade
du travail parlementaire il fallait un
juge de paix c'est le rôle quenant jou
le Sénat aujourd'hui sous la houlette de
notre cher président commission des
affaires sociales à Millon et sous la
houlette des rapporteurs Catherine
Desroche Élisabeth douanau dont je salue
au passage le très goon travail qui a
été fait en amont après examen en
commission le texte est plus équilibré
mais nous ne souhaitons pas qu'il soit
détricoté il demeure tout de même encore
trois fois plus volumineux que le projet
initial notre commission en effet
conservé nombre des apports de
l'Assemblée nationale sur le fond
l'effort de colégislation se retrouve
dans chacune des grandes parties du
projet en matière de prévention nous
pouvons nous féliciter de voir aborderé
des sujets aussi important que la lutte
contre l'alcoolisme l'obésité l'anorexie
le tabagisme la drogue et même les
cabines de bronzage
mais pour ne parler que l'une de de ces
mesures la plus emblématique du texte
l'expérimentation des salles de choot je
crois pour dire pouvoir dire que nombre
de parlementaires étaient au départ très
sceptiqu mais les les médecins
adictologues étant unanime pour soutenir
l'expérimentation et ils ont su
convaincre certains de nos
collègues dans le même temps pas tous
j'ai dit certains dans le même temps
nous pouvons soutenir l'effort fournis
par notre commission pour tempérer
l'ardeur du gouvernement sur le paquet
neutre pourquoi surtransposer la
directiv européennes avant même de
disposer de l'évaluation des expériences
menées à l'étranger la même question
peut se poser d'ailleurs pour l'article
11 quat qui interdit la présence du
bisphénol A dans les jouets à musettes
là encore il y a surtransposition de
directive en ce qui concerne la
simplification et l'amélioration de la
lisibilité du système la systématisation
des lettres de lésion entre villes et
hôpital la relance nécessaire du dossier
médical personnalisé la réinscription
dans la lois du service public
hospitalier sont des avancées tout à
fait notables mais je voudrais insister
sur le fait que si une réorganisation
territoriale de l'orre de soins est
indispensable elle ne peut être réalisée
que de façon coordonnée et concertée
avec les professionnels de santé et les
élus par exemple bon nombre de médecins
m'ont rencontré des médecins
généralistes il souhaitent que
l'organisation des soins primaires et
celle des seconds recours soi nettement
individualisé dans le cadre des
communautés professionnelles
territoriales de santé c'est aussi la
condition de la réussite du groupement
hospitalier du territoire créé par
l'article 27 du du présent texte or nous
sommes inquiets de constater que nous
savons que des ght commence déjà à se
constituer avant même que la loi ne soit
votée j'en terminerai par l'amélioration
d'accès aux soins au sujet de ce sujet
je crois que le débat a été focalisé je
dirai même pollué par la généralisation
du tipayen que le Cher BV en bénéficie
aux assurés les plus modestes nous y
sommes bien sûr totalement favorables
mais c'est déjà le cas en partie puisque
le Cher payant existe pour toutes les
personnes dont le niveau de revenu est
inférieur ou égal au seuil de pauvreté
monétaire dans certains cabinets
médicaux cela représente actuellement 30
% des consultations
matondit peut-être aurait-on pu élargir
la tranche de bénéficière du tier payant
à d'autres personnes au revenus encore
trop modestes mais l'étendre à tous les
assurés conduit à une banalisation de
l'acte et pour un médecin on pense que
c'est l'alimenté la bobologie qui plombe
l'activité médicale ce que les médecins
attindre c'est une reconnaissance de
leur profession car leur mission
consiste dans la réalité des faits à une
prise en charge globale des personnes et
même des familles le médecin est celui
qui soigne celui qui écoute celui qui
conseille de plus dans le fond certains
particiens vivent le Cher payant comme
un moyen détourner d'annoncer la fin de
l'exercice libéral et ça a été dit et
pourtant et pourtant et c'est un fait
nouveau nombreux d'entre eux
accepteraient cette évolution en
contrepartie de conditions de travail
compatible avec la qualité de vie à
laquelle ils aspirent à nos yeux la
participation du bénéficiaire relève
beaucoup plus de la moralisation du
système et la question de
l'accessibilité aux soins dépasse de
loin le débat sur la généralisation du
tier
payant le texte porte certaines mesures
très encourageantes ainsi en est-il de
l'article 12 bis qui tel que modifié par
la commission revient à renforcer les
pôles de santé pour regrouper les
professionnels du premierours en
coordination avec ceux de second recours
de l'article 15 qui encore une fois
amendé par la commission crée un numéro
véritablement unique tout en préservant
l'activité des médecins libéraux
regroupés en association de permanence
des soins donc SOS médecin pour ne pas
les nommer qui ne se sentaiit menacé par
le dispositif initialement initialement
proposé mais l'accès aux soins c'est
aussi la question du temps médical qui
pose le problème des délégations d'actes
entre professionnels et de l'émergence
de nouvelles professions ici encore le
texte va vraiment dans le bon sens mais
si c tendance inévitablement à terme
elle n'est quesquissée et nous et nous
pensons qu'il faudra aller plus loin
enfin ENF on peut parler d'accès aux
soins sans on ne peut pas parler d'accès
aux soins sans aborder le débat sur la
désertification médicale nous l'aurons
avec l'article 12 quur a par lequel
notre commission crée une obligation de
négocier sur le conventionnement des
médecins souhaitant s'installer en zone
sousdans et zone surd c'est une piste ce
n'est qu'une piste certains de nos
collègues ont une position beaucoup plus
contraignante et vous l'avez déjà
entendu au cours de ce débat général on
peut toutefois d'emblé regretter que le
texte n'est pas assz l'accent sur
l'orientation des étudiants en médecine
vers la médecine généraliste et
l'exercice regroupé parce que c'est le
plus beau métier du monde mais
l'exercice solitaire pose vraiment un de
plus en plus de problèm or c'est bien
médecin généraliste qui constitue la
porte d'entrée du parcours de soins
auquel Madame le Ministre on le sait
vous tenezint merci de votre attention
merci Monsieur roche la parole est
maintenant au dernier orateur inscrit
monsieur Yv dodini pour le groupe
socialiste et
républicain
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
les rapporteurs madame la ministre mes
chers collègues ce projet de loi
s'inscrit dans un contexte de
transformation majeure en matière de
santé publique l'ouverture en juin
dernier vous étiez présente madame la
ministre l'un Nouveau Centre de
Recherche et Développement consacré aux
maladies rares par le laboratoire
àextion à l'Institut imagine à Paris PUL
européen qui associe recherche et soins
des maladies génétiques confirme
l'excellence de la recherche médicale et
scientifique française que concrétise le
grand nombre de brevets déposés et de
premières mondiales réalisé dans nos
centres Hospitalier Universitaire
l'innovation française est en pointe
grâce aux professionnels et au personnel
de santé qui la font vivre au quotidien
et aussi au gouvernement qui y prend
toute sa part il vient notamment de
financer dans le cadre du programme
d'investissement d'avenir plusieurs
projets de recherche de grande ampleur
dans le domaine de la santé associant la
recherche fondamental la recherche
clinique et les entreprises les
nouvelles thérapies ont aussi un coût
que nous connaiss que nous n
connaissions pas jusqu'àors nous y avons
été confrontés très récemment s'agissant
du traitement de l'hépatite C et il est
aussi de la responsabilité de l'État
parce que la nation est
constitutionnellement garante de la
protection de la santé sens large où la
défin l'OMS d'en assurer l'accès à tous
les patients à cet égard le projet de
loi ne comporte pas de dispositions
financières que la cohérence budgétaire
réserve à juste titre aux lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale mais
la situation de nos comptes sociaux
conditionne bien sûr la viabilité de
nombre de mesures qui il comporte de
même qu'elle conditionne l'accès de tous
au nouveaux traitements et à
l'innovation que seul un système de
financement solidaire permet je
mentionne simplement nous y reviendrons
de manière précise en novembre prochain
que pour 2014 tous les soldes de branche
se sont améliorés par rapport à 2013 et
que le déficit du régime général et du
fond de solidarité vieillesse est réduit
de moitié ce contexte globalement plus
favorable doit être souligné
rappelez-vous en 2009 quelle était la
situation au moment de l'adoption de la
loi Hôpital Patient Santé et territoire
les perspectives étaient alors
extrêmement sombres et nous avons changé
aussi cela il n'est pas inutile de le
rappeler aux impératifs d'adaptation et
de transformation de notre système de
santé que nécessite l'investissement
dans la recherche et innovation à ce que
nous imposent les mutations
démographiques et épidémiologique que
nous connaissons s'ajoute un impératif
plus catégorique encore celui de la
justice sociale et c'est ce à quoi ce
projet de loi entend répondre le rapport
statistique annuelle du Secours
Catholique le rapport de l'adresse sur
l'état de santé de la population
l'enquête de l'Observatoire de l'égalité
d'accès aux soins de mai 2015 établisse
le même constat si l'état de en France
est globalement bon il comporte de
nombreuses et notables disparités entre
territoires et catégories sociale
l'existence et l'importance des
problèmes de santé sont d'abord liés à
la position sociale et au niveau
d'étude ainsi ce sont souvent les mêmes
populations les moins favorisées qui
cumulent les facteurs défavorables selon
la hiérarchie sociale le gradient social
de santé diminue ou augmente de même que
les inégalités de recours aux soins la
vision non corrigée mal corrigée est
aussi corrélée au niveau de vie et à des
facteurs
socioéconomique dans un tel contexte ne
pas soutenir le principe de
généralisation du tiers payant constitue
un grave dén de réalité et de justice
pour répondre au défis majeurs de
l'accès aux soins et dans le cadre des
orientations fixées par la stratégie
nationale de santé ce projet de loi fait
de la prévention le socle de la
politique publique structure le parcours
de santé autour des soins primaires fait
évoluer les métiers et favorise la
recherche clarifie la gouvernance de la
politique de santé renforce la
transparence et la démocratie
sanitaire santé scolaire
contraception dépistage refondation du
service public hospitalier pratiques
avancées droit à l'oubli action de
groupe et bien oui grande part très
grande part de ce projet est approuvé
par les Français et d'ailleurs quoi
qu'Al en dise également par notre
commission des affaires sociales au long
au-delà des suppressions fortes qui ont
déjà été évoquées car si je cite son
rapport plus d'une centaine d'articles
sans modification ou moyennant de simple
précision
rédactionnelle la généralisation du
tiers payant a essentiellement focalisé
l'attention il est vrai perspective des
élections professionnelles 12 octobre
prochain prête à la surenchère
elle n'explique ni ne justifie toutefois
d'autres excès proches de la caricature
s'agissant des salles de consommation à
moindre risque ou de la suppression du
délai de réflexion pour
l'IVG vrai aussi d'ailleurs il y a pas
si longtemps certains demandaient le
rétablissement du délit
d'auto-avortement et la prison pour ces
femmes en détresse reconnaissons à notre
ministre des Affaires sociales et de la
santé et des droits des femmes un
courage certain pour avoir résisté à la
violence verbale et aux attaques qui se
sont données libre cours et jusqu'où
serait-on allé si le projet comportait
comme certains le proposaient une
installation déconventionnée en zone sur
de
la suppression des régimes spéciaux ou
l'unification du régime général et des
complémentaires en réalité ce projet n'a
pas comme l'écrivent les rapporteurs de
notre commission suscité une réaction de
profond
rejet nombre de représentants des
professions de santé que nous avons
auditionné nous ont dit en approuver
l'essentiel mesames Messieurs chers
collègues de la majorité un effet
d'optique médiatique vous aur a a fait
prendre une partie pour le tout madame
la ministre à vos côtés nous avancerons
dans ce débat de manière pragmatique et
sereine avec la même ambition que vous
avez exprimé dans votre propos pour la
justice et la République sociale je vous
remercie merci Monsieur dadini la
discussion générale est closeuse nous
passons à la discussion du texte de la
commission ah pardon excusez-moi madame
ministre vous avez la parole bien
évidemment
hein merci monsieur le Président j'en
abuserai pas je m'y engage je voulais
d'abord remercier l'ensemble des
intervenants pour la qualité de leur
présentation et éventuellement de leurs
interpellations je ne vais pas rentrer
dans le détail précisément des diverses
interpellations qui ont été faites sur
l'ensemble des sujets que comporte ce
projet de loi nous aurons l'occasion au
moment de l'examen des des articles
d'entrer dans des débats plus
approfondis et je veux rassurer monsieur
Barbier parce que mon décompte n'est pas
exactement le même si mes calculs
arithmétiques sont justes c'est plutôt
près de 75 heures que nous devrions
passer ensemble dans cette hémicycle ce
qui nous donnera largement le temps de
débattre de l'ensemble de ces questions
je voudrais bien sûr remercier tout
particulièrement Catherine Génisson Yv
dodini et Alina chambau non seulement du
soutien qu'ils ont apporté au nom de
leur groupe à ce texte mais aussi de
leur intervention qui a bien mis en
évidence la logique la cohérence des
objectifs qui sont recherchés dans ce
texte et qui a mis en avant qui ont mis
en avant leurs
interventions le caractère structurant
structurel de toute une série de mesures
et donc je dois dire que je suis un peu
étonnée de la longue présentation de
Monsieur bas qui visait à montrer que la
loi était au fond inutile sur toute une
série de questions parce que au fond
expliquer que les mesures qui ont été
supprimées n'ont pas de caractère
normatif c'est un peu osé lorsque les
mesures supprimées c'est la
généralisation du tiers payant la mise
en place du paquet neutre la suppression
du délai de réflexion pour
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
le réétablissement du service public
hospitalier l'action de group GRP en
santé j'en passe et des meilleurs
expliquer que ce ne sont pas des mesures
normatives qui ne portent pas une vision
de notre projet de santé de notre
système de santé je dois dire que j'ai
un peu de mal à le suivre sur ce terrain
ainsi que les autres intervenants qui
sont allés dans cette direction et je
veux dire que j'assume pleinement au nom
du gouvernement en mon nom prope le fait
qu'il y ait des différences de vision
des différences d'approches des
différences de conception de ce que doit
être un projet de santé au service de
notre société au service de la
solidarité au service de nos concitoyens
pour l'accès aux soins parce que il ne
suffit pas de dire à une tribune ou
ailleurs que l'on est favorable à la
prévention je l'ai dit la prévention et
sans doute le mot le plus largement
utilisé et le plus largement partagé
dans notre pays encore faut-il être
capable de se retrouver sur des instr
instuments concrets qui vont permettre
de décliner ces objectifs et je veux
dire avec force que moi aussi je suis
favorable à la responsabilité de nos
concitoyens moi je ne crois pas du tout
qu'en matière de santé l'état puisse se
substituer à la volonté des citoyens de
porter des comportements d'avoir des
comportements favorables à leur santé
mais je veux récuser avec la plus grande
force idé que il y aurait une
responsabilité qui tomberait du ciel et
qui au fond ne tiendrait pas compte des
réalités sociales des réalités
culturelles des réalités de comment dire
de groupe et d'incitation du groupe où
est la responsabilité d'un gamin et je
dis volontairement d'un gamin de 12 ans
lorsqu'il commence à fumer à la sortie
du collège pour faire comme ses copains
comme le groupe social auquel